bonjour à tous au mois de mars dernier
François Hollande a annoncé un choc de
simplification simplification
administrative simplification fiscale
mais aussi simplification dans la vie
des entreprise c'est ainsi que Bercy le
ministère de l'Économie a préparé un
projet de loi permettant à l'état de
procéder par ordonnance à la matière
c'est-à-dire sans passer par le
Parlement sans passer par le législateur
objectif alléger les obligations
comptables des petites entreprises
simplifier le droit des entreprises en
difficulté clarifier le droit des
sociétés tout cela afin de permettre aux
entreprises de renouer avec plus de
compétitivité tout de suite retour donc
à cette séance qui s'est déroulée hier
après-midi au
Sénat l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée d'habilitation
à prendre par ordonnance diverses
mesures de simplification et de
sécurisation de la vie des
entreprises dans la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame flore pèlerin
ministre chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises de l'innovation et de
l'économie
numérique vous vous avez la parole
madame la
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je voudrais tout
d'abord vous remercier de me donner la
possibilité de vous exposer les grandes
lignes de ce projet de loi
d'habilitation à simplifier et sécuriser
la vie des entreprise ce projet vous le
savez s'inscrit dans le choc de
simplification annoncé et voulu par le
président de la République il a donc
fait l'objet d'un engagement collectif
du gouvernement autour de pierre
moscoviss qui a porté ce texte je tiens
à remercier particulièrement tan Mohamed
SW pardon yannique Vaugrenard Laurence
trossignol François patria qui en ont
été les rapporteurs en commission je
souhaiterais d'abord rappeler l'enjeu de
ce projet de loi il s'agit ni plus ni
moins de libérer les énergies des
entreprises en simplifiant et en
sécurisant leur action l'objectif est de
leur permettre de consacrer davantage de
temps et de moyens à leur métier à leur
cœur de métier et moins à leur papierers
selon la Commission européenne a baissé
de 25 % les charges administratives des
entreprises c'est retrouver 1,4 % de PIB
supplémentaire à long terme si beaucoup
de mesures portées par ces textes sont
des mesures simples leur impact est donc
potentiellement très grand y compris à
l'échelle macro-économique notre
ambition est également grande pour
l'administration car la simplification
est pour elle un changement de paradigme
elle suppose une adaptation
technologique pour prendre le virage de
la dématérialisation et des
téléprocédures elle suppose également de
par faaire une évolution culturelle car
simplifier la vie des entreprise c'est
entrer dans une relation de confiance
éviter les contrôles redondants ne pas
demander plusieurs fois le même
justificatif ce changement de paradigme
est nécessaire pour disposer demain d'un
service public moins coûteux pour le
contribuable plus à l'écoute des
entreprises et encore plus efficace
qu'il n est aujourd'hui dans cette
mesure ce projet de loi s'inscrit dans
la dynamique plus générale de la
modernisation de l'action publique les
habilitations que le gouvernement
sollicite du Parlement sont très variées
puisque des idées ont émergé de notre
concertation avec les entreprises et les
administrations de proximité dans de
très nombreux domaines ainsi
prévoyons-nous l'allègement des
obligations comptables des petites
entreprises la suppression de certaines
déclarations redondantes ou encore la
simplification de certaines obligations
d'affichage des employeurs mais
simplifier la vie des entreprises touche
à bien d'autres dimensions allant du
financement à la sécurisation de leur
environnement juridique ce projet de loi
comporte ainsi des mesures en faveur du
financement participatif auquel je suis
personnellement attaché car elle profite
très largement au projets de jeune pous
du numérique il porte également
plusieurs mesures d'urgence telles que
la ratification ou la transposition de
directive dont l'échéance d'importation
dans l'ordre juridique interne est
imminente ou bien encore la mise en
œuvre de la partie non fiscale de la
très importante réforme de l'assurance
vie consistant à créer les contrats
eurocroissance qui vous le savez
contribueront au financement des entre
prise en favorisant l'investissement en
action le paradoxe est bien connu et ce
projet de loi ne pouvait y échapper
entièrement il est souvent très complexe
de simplifier mais si les sujets sont
divers la démarche de simplification
résulte de choix politiqu clair et je
souhaite rappeler quelques grands axes
premièrement notre démarche de
simplification n'est pas une démarche de
dérégulation elle ne serurait conduire à
remettre en cause des acquis sociaux ou
environnementaux en effet plusieurs
mesures emblématiques de ce projet de
loi visent à raccourci en les fusionnant
des procédures d'autorisation complexes
en matière d'urbanisme ou
d'environnement c'est la logique par
exemple du certificat de projet des
procédures intégrées pour l'immobilier
d'entreprise ou les installations
classées ou encore des opérations
d'intérêt économique et environnemental
mais dans chacune de ces procédures plus
grande diligence ne rimera pas avec
moindre vigilance de même les mesures
d'allèigement de certaines obligations
des employeurs ou encore les mesures
proposées en matière de gouvernance des
entreprises dans lesquelles l'État
détient une participation ne serait en
aucun cas se traduire par un recul des
droits des
salariés deuxièmement si le gouvernement
souhaite procéder par ordonnance c'est à
fin d'agir vite et fort c'est la raison
pour laquelle les délais d'habilitation
qui vous sont demandés sont courts nous
souhaitons que la très grande majorité
des ordonnance soit paru d'ici à la fin
du printemps
2014 mais là encore habilitation ne
signifie pas dépossession du Parlement
et je renouvelle très sincèrement auprès
de vous l'engagement qui a été pris
devant l'Assemblée nationale nous
souhaitons que les parlementaires
puissent être associé pleinement à
l'élaboration des ordonnances enfin
troisièmement j'insiste sur l'honnêteté
de notre démarche les habilitation que
le gouvernement sollicite de votre Haute
Assemblée n'ont pour seul et unique
objet que de faciliter l'action des
entreprises françaises et d'améliorer
leur environnement de la réforme des
rapports entre le syndicat des
transports d'Île-de-France et la Société
du Grand Paris à la modernisation de
l'État actionnaire en passant par
l'amélioration des procédures
collectives notre projet ne repose que
sur des évolutions que nous espérons
fédératrices et je me réjouis de pouvoir
détailler devant que je me réjouis de
pouvoir détailler devant vous ce soir
merci beaucoup merci madame la
ministre dans la suite de la discussion
la parole est à Monsieur T Mohamed so
rapporteur de la commission des lois
monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues les
entreprises approuvent réclame les
simplifications prévues dans ce projet
de loi nous devons tous les entendre un
seul exemple les allèigement comptable
prévu à l'article 1er du texte vont
simplifier la vie de 97 % des sociétés
commerciales celle de 50 salariés ou
plus sans pour autant remettre en cause
le modèle comptable français nous sommes
nombreux dans cette émicycle à
considérer que la simplification est un
facteur parmi d'autres bien sûr de
compétitivité économique pour nos
entreprises et à partager cette priorité
j'espère que cette préoccupation qui
nous est commune et qui dépasse dans ses
finalités les clivages partisan saura
nous rassembler au moment de fater ce
projet de loi certes le gouvernement
nous propose de procéder par voie
d'ordonnance et nous sommes à nouveau
saisis cette année d'un projet de loi
d'habilitation nous en avons déjà
examiné deux mais quel gouvernement n'a
pas eu recours à cette faculté prévue
par notre Constitution y compris pour
simplifier le droit pour réformer le
droit des entreprises en difficulté
comme ce fut le cas en 2008 ce projet de
loi traduit les engagements du
gouvernement envers les entreprises en
matière de choc de simplification qui
ont été pris notamment lors du comité
interministériel pour la modernisation
de l'action publique du 17 juillet
dernier la simplification est devenue un
processus permanent depuis une dizaine
d'années et à cet égard le gouvernement
actuel lui accorde au moins la même
priorité que le gouvernement précédent
même si les méthodes législatives de
simplification peuvent changer nous
exprimions tous il n'y a pas si
longtemps encore les mêmes réticences à
l'égard des propositions de loi de
simplification du droit très volumineus
et pas toujours très intelligible pour
le débat parlementaire notre collègue
Bernard soget rapporteur de trois de ces
textes a même parlé d'assemblage
hétéroclite de cavalier législatif en
désérance il faut bien reconnaître
qu'avec le projet de loi qui nous est
soumis aujourd'hui nous n'en sommes plus
là même si l'on peut en discuter ce
texte est bien centré sur le droit des
entreprises sur la simplification de la
vie des entreprises avec des mesures
générales et des mesures plus
sectorielles ce texte a un objet clair
et circonscrit et la navette
parlementaire ne l'a pas encore trop
alourdi il faut saluer cet effort de
modération de la part du gouvernement
alors c'est vrai ce projet de loi
procède par voie d'habilitation mais il
ne s'agit pas pour autant d'un blancin
car l'habilitation doit être
suffisamment précise pour éclairer le
législateur sur les mesures envisagées
comme l'a exigé le Conseil
constitutionnel à de nombreuses reprises
le sens du travail de la commission et
des amendements qu'elle a adopté à a
justement été de préciser les
habilitations lorsqu'elles étaient trop
vagues ou imprécises y compris et j'en
suis navré madame la ministre lorsque le
gouvernement aurait préféré une
habilitation plus floue lui donnant une
plus grande marge de manœuvre j'entends
que la méthode du recours aux
ordonnances n'est pas satisfaisante en
particulier pour les sujets qui excèdent
la seule simplification c'est-à-dire les
véritables réformes qui méritent un
projet de loi à part entière et un vrai
examen parlementaire au fond
je pense en particulier à l'article 2 du
projet de loi qui propose une large
réforme une large réforme du droit des
entreprises en difficulté sur ce sujet
cependant le gouvernement invoque à
juste titre l'urgence de la situation
économique pour procéder par ordonnance
je souscris bien évidemment à cet
argument de réalisme à cette égard il
faut reconnaître que les délais
d'habilitation sont dans leur grande
majorité assez courts entre 4 et 9 mois
l'argument de la rapidité n'est donc pas
sans fondement même si nous aurions pu
dans certains cas examiner un projet de
loi y compris en procédure accélérée en
tout état de cause il appartiendra au
parlementairirees que nous sommes et ce
sera le cas de la commission des lois
pour ce qui la concerne d'être vigilant
lorsque nous serons invités à ratifier
ces ordonnances si nous le jugeons
nécessaire de les modifier madame la
ministre j'ai bien entendu tout à
l'heure votre eng agement à associer les
parlementaires à ces à ces
ordonnances madame la ministre nous
devrons examiner les projets de loi de
ratification en particulier celui
concernant le droit des entreprises en
difficulté cette ratification devra
faire l'objet d'un réel débat
parlementaire la Commission n'a pas
souhaité dans un souci de rapidité et
d'efficacité et dans le respect de la
logique d'ensemble de ces textes
d'habilitation et adjoindre des
dispositions additionnelles des modif
tion du droit en vigueur même si les
suggestions de simplification formulées
par les entreprises sont toujours
nombreuses nous pourrons toujours y
revenir mais certaines dispositions de
ce projet de loi sont attendues et
doivent s'appliquer dès le début de
l'année 2014 de sorte que nous n'avons
pas voulu alourdir ce texte je précise
cela car nous aurons à examiner tout à
l'heure quelques amendements proposant
d'introduire des dispositions
additionnelles je me suis moi-même à ne
pas en proposer à la commission je
propose de nous entenir à cette ligne de
conduite par cohérence comme je l'ai
indiqué en début de mon intervention les
représentants des entreprises ainsi que
des professionnels qui les accompagnent
approuvent sans guerre de réserve les
finalités envisagées pour les
ordonnances je mets bien sûr de côté
l'article 16 sur la Signaléthique du tri
les nombreuses auditions que j'ai mené
me l'ont
confirmé avant d'en venir à une
présentation rapide du contenu du projet
de loi et de ses habilitations les plus
importantes je vous rappelle que la
Commission a décidé de déléguer l'examen
au fond des articles 8 et 16 à la
commission du développement durable et
des article 11 12 15 et 21 à la
commission des finances nous nous en
sommes donc remis par principe pour ces
articles et pour les amendements qui
portent sur ces articles à la position
de la Commission délégataire euh à à la
position que la Commission délégataire
avait adopté je ne les évoquerai donc
pas dans mon intervention pour achever
de convaincre nos collègues s'ils en
doutaient encore de l'utilité d'adopter
ce projet attendu par les entreprises
françaises je souhaite présenter
quelques-unes de ces dispositions les
plus significatives comme je l'aiindiqué
en introduction en conformité avec une
nouvelle directive comptable de 2013 le
projet de loi propose d'alléger les
obligations comptables des petites
entreprises sans supprimer l'obligation
de dépôt des comptes au Registre du
Commerce et des Sociétés et d'ouvrir un
droit d'option pour la publication des
comptes des très petites entreprises de
10 salariés ou plus ce droit d'option ne
serait pas ouvert aux petites
entreprises de 50 salariés ou plus au
nom de la transparence vis-à-vis des
tiers le projet de loi prévoit également
de rendre obligatoire la facturation
électronique des mat réalisé entre les
personnes publiques et leurs
fournisseurs la Commission a prévu que
cette obligation serait étalée dans le
temps pour tenir compte des capacités
des petites entreprises l'habilitation
relative à la réforme du droit des
entreprises en difficulté vise à
renforcer le volet fondamental de la
prévention qui permet d'anticiper des
difficultés notamment en rendant les
mesures et procédure de prévention plus
attractive et moins coûteuse pour les
entreprises et en incitant davantage les
créan ci à s'investir dans une solution
de continuité de l'activité de
l'entreprise le texte propose également
de réformer différents aspects des
procédures collectives il s'agit
notamment de s'inspirer de la procédure
de sauvegarde financière accélérée créé
à l'initiative de Jean jean-jacquest en
2010 qui n'a été utilisé que quatre fois
mais qui suscite beaucoup d'intérêt dans
son principe pour mettre en place une
nouvelle procédure de sauvegarde
également ouverte aux créanciers non
financier en cas d'échec d'une procédure
de
conciliation ceci doit également rendre
la conciliation plus attractive le texte
prévoit de revoir l'équilibre entre les
différents acteurs des procédures
collectives notamment en adaptant les
droits des actionnaires pour favoriser
l'émergence d'une solution de
continuation de l'activité le cas
échéant à l'aide des créanciers qui
pourrait présenter un plan
alternatif il propose de de simplifier
les procédures liquidatives on parle de
procédure de liquidation ultra
simplifiée en 3 mois de procédures
spécifiques de liquidation pour les
débiteurs sans actif net de facilitation
de la clôture pour insuffisance d'actif
et de lever du dessaisissement du
débiteur personne physique avant la
clôture de la liquidation pour lui
permettre de rcréer une activité enfin
le projet de loi vise à améliorer les
procédures juridic
devant le tribunal de commerce notamment
en précisant les critères de renvoi
devant une autre juridiction ce qui est
une question récurrente en renforçant
encore la présence du ministère public
garant de l'ordre public économique et
seul magistrat professionnel présent et
en clarifiant le rôle et le statut du
juge commissaire conformément à
l'exigence d'impartialité sur le droit
des difficultés des entreprises la
Commission a adopté une série de
modifications
pour préciser le champ des habilitations
le projet de loi comporte également un
volet sur le droit des sociétés
reprenant notamment des recommandations
de l'Autorité des marchés financiers
pour simplifier le régime des
conventions réglementées passé entre une
société et ses dirigeants tout en
conservant une exigence de transparence
le texte vise aussi à clarifier le
régime de rachat des actions de
préférence et à faire évoluer la
législation aux valeurs mobilières
notamment pour les titres financiers
complexes la Commission a précisé cette
habilitation il comporte aussi d'autres
simplifications ponctuelles pour le
droit des sociétés par exemple la
possibilité de prolonger le délai de
convocation de l'assemblée des associés
dans une société à responsabilité
limitée ou la possibilité pour une
entreprise unipersonnel à responsabilité
limitée d'être l'associé unique d'une
autre entreprise unipersonnel à
responsabilité limitée le texte concerne
aussi certaines professions réglementées
il prévoit d'augmenter le nombre de
notaires salarié par office notarial
d'ouvrir l'exercice l'exercice salarié
pour la profession d'avocat au Conseil
d'État et à la Cour de cassation et de
modifier certaines conditions d'exercice
de la profession d'expert comptable ces
habilitations concernent bien la vie des
entreprises car ces trois professions
réglementées sont des entreprises mais
sont aussi impliquées dans la vie de
entreprises mes auditions là aussi me
l'ont montré le texte clarifie aussi les
obligations des mutueles et des
établissements de crédit en matière de
publication d'informations sociale et
environnementale pour les aligner sur
les obligations générales des sociétés
anonymes avec les mêmes critères il
s'agit de l'application de seuil et de
modalités particulières consolidées au
sein des groupes il vise également à
moderniser les règles d'organisation et
de fonctionnement des entreprises dans
lesquels l'État détient une
participation dans le prolongement des
réflexions en cours sur le rôle de
l'État actionnaire l'objectif consiste
en particulier à simplifier ces règles
souvent rigides et obsolètes pour les
rapprocher du droit commun des société
et à faire évoluer les règles de
composition des conseils
d'administration et de désignation des
représentants de l'État et des
dirigeants la Commission a clarifié
cette habilitation cont toutefois des
inquiétudes qui s'expriment je vous
proposerai un amendement pour préciser
que cette évolution ne doit pas remettre
en cause la représentation des salariés
au sein des conseils par ailleurs dans
le prolongement des travaux sur la
modernisation du droit de
l'environnement auquel participe
activement notre collègue Alain Richard
le projet de loi propose d'expérimenter
et mécanisme de certificat de projet
garantissant la stabilité des normes
applicables et simplifiant le traitement
administratif de certains projets ainsi
qu'un système de décision unique du
préfet pour les installations classées
pour la protection de
l'environnement ces habilitations on ont
été précisées en commission s'agissant
notamment de la question des voies de
recours et ont été complété par
voie par par deux expérimentations
complémentaire le texte comporte
également sur proposition du
gouvernement une habilitation en vue de
mettre en place un nouveau produit
d'assurance vie davantage orienté vers
le financement de l'économie on ne peut
quiy souscrire je sais je séigré au
gouvernement de ne pas avoir mêlé à
cette habilitation la question du droit
de renonciation en assurance vie sujet
bien distinct qui ne relève pas de la
simplification comme je l'ai dit la
Commission a été attentive à la
précision et à la clarté des
habilitations le Conseil constitutionnel
nous nous y a régulièrement invité c'est
une garantie de transparence et de
loyauté lorsque nous acceptons
d'autoriser le gouvernement à intervenir
pour une durée limitée et pour un objet
précis dans le domaine de la loi qui est
le nôtre avant de conclure je tiens à
remercier sincèrement les trois
rapporteurs pour avis Yannick vugrenard
au nom de la commission des affaires
économiques Laurence rousignol au nom de
la commission du développement durable
et François patria au nom de la
commission des finances pour les
contributions à l'examen de ce texte mes
chers collègues je vous propose donc
d'adopter ce projet de loi je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur la
parole est à Monsieur Yannick vugonard
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires
économiques monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur rapporteur pour avis mes chers
collègues quelques mots pour vous
résumer l'avis de la commission des
affaires économiques sur ce projet de
loi qui concerne le volet concern
consacré aux entreprises pardon du choc
de
simplification je rappelle cependant que
les entreprises ne sont pas les seuls à
souhaiter un allongement des charges
administratives ou de l'impôt papier
comme l'appelle certains les citoyens
aussi bien que par ailleurs il n'hésite
pas à se tourner de façon parfaitement
légitime vers les pouvoirs publics pour
demander parfois plus de normes le
gouvernement dont la tâche n'est donc
ici encore pas facile a cependant bien
prise en compte cette aspiration à la
simplicité et le parlement vient
d'adopter la loi du 12 novembre 2013
habilitant le gouvernement à simplifier
la relation donc entre l'administration
et les citoyens par ailleurs madame la
ministre je le redis ici au Sénat nos
collectivités territoriales luttent
quotidiennement contre la lenteur et les
engrenages des procédures chacun
s'accorde à constater les difficultés
mais les solutions y apporté ne sont pas
simples comme en témoigne la navette
parlementaire sur la proposition de loi
d'origine sénatoriale relative à la
simplification du fonctionnement de nos
collectivités territoriales aujourd'hui
en seconde lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale nous appelons donc le
gouvernement à tenir compte de ces
difficultés en encourageant en
particulier l'administration de l'État à
faciliter la vie sur l'ensemble de nos
territoires après ces observations jeen
reviens à l'analyse spécifique de ce
projet de loi d'habilitation consacré
aux entreprises
le principal message sur le fond de la
commission des affaires économiques est
que la démarche fivie par le
gouvernement est de nature à redonné
vigueur et crédibilité à la démarche de
simplification voulue par tous de
manière plus précise nous insistons sur
l'objectif qui consiste à faire
progresser notre pays en compétitivité
temps en effet depuis les années 50 on
répète le mot simplification et on prend
des mesures censé aller dans ce sens
mais personne n'a pu arrêter cependant
la profusion de normes dans tous les
domaines dans tous les pays et même au
niveau international comme en témoigne
la multiplication des règles de
l'organisation mondial du commerce le
processus de simplification a bien
failli au cours des années récentes être
lui-même emporté par cette tendance
inflationiste si nous parvenons enfin à
réduire le foisonnement tant mieux mais
si nous n'y parvenons pas immédiatement
le projet de loi d'habilitation des
contient des palliatifs essentiels pour
gérer la complexité ainsi que
l'instabilité de façon plus simple et
plus rapide pour l'usager j'observe que
les industriels ont été confrontés à un
défi un peu SIM similaire finalement à
celui du législateur les objets que nous
utilisons sont de plus en plus complexes
mais leur maniement c'est simplifié pour
se mettre finalement à la portée de tous
il y a encore 30 ans il fallait
communiquer avec un ordinateur en
langage machine et non pas avec un
simple clic ou en effleurant un écran
les les logiciels permettent ainsi de
traiter beaucoup d'informations en peu
de temps et la r administration est
susceptible de générer selon les
estimations 15 milliards d'économie
budgétaire pour l'État et un alléement
de 25 % de la charge administrative pour
les entreprises c'est dans cette
direction que se sont orientés les
exemples et bonnes pratiques conduites
chez nos voisins européens en matière de
réduction de la charge administrative et
de généralisation de l'administration
électronique c'est aussi le premier axe
fondamental du présent projet de loi
avec par exemple la facture tion
électronique prévu par l'article 1er
rappelons que l'État traite manuellement
des quantités énormes de papiers
correspondant à plus de 4 millions de
factures par an dont certaines
atteignent des centaines de pages au nom
du réalisme observons cependant
l'actualité récente aux États-Unis qui
montre que la réussite de l'
administration ne va pas de soi même
dans ce pays pionnier en matière de
technologie de l'information la
saturation des sites internet publics a
en effet fragilisé le le lancement de
son vaste programme dit auamaker de
généralisation de la couverture maladie
c'est pourquoi la Commission des
Affaires économique attache une grande
importance au maintien des dispositions
du projet de loi qui prévoit une
extension mais progressive des
obligations d'utiliser les outils de la
administration et un traitement
particulier des très petites entreprises
qui n'auraient pas les moyens de se
mettre aux normes techniques le choc de
simplification ne peut et ne doit pas
être ne doit pas entraîner de surcout
pour les entreprises bien entendu
deuxièmement l'expérimentation du
certificat de projet prévu par les
articles 13 et 14 offre des perspectives
stable aux opérateurs sans pour autant
brider le Parlement dans ses initiatives
de perfectionnement du droit le texte
s'attaque donc à la principale antise
des porteurs de projets qui est
l'instabilité des normes plus encore que
leur complexité parfois les grands axes
de ce projet emportent donc l'adhésion
d'autant qu'il a été construit sur la
bas base d'une consultation au cours de
laquelle non seulement les
administrations mais aussi surtout les
entreprises ont pu directement exprimer
leur propres besoins cette adhésion est
d'autant plus nécessaire que la
simplification de la vie des entreprises
ne relève pas seulement des normes
législatives ou réglementaires mais
aussi des comportements par exemple il a
été constaté que certaines
administrations ou certains greffes des
tribunaux de commerce n'ont pas toujours
des pratiques homogènes sur l'ensemble
du territoire et des justificatifs sont
parfois demandé sans que cela soit prévu
par notre règlementation de ce point de
vue il est essentiel que le gouvernement
et le Parlement diffusent ensemble un
message de simplification générale de la
vie des entreprises à la société
française ainsi qu'à son administration
je ferai cependant au nom de la
commission des affaires économiques deux
observations qui concernent le recours
aux ordonnances à force de le contester
par principe on ne vient par oublier que
si le gouvernement ne s'y oppose pas le
le Parlement conserve juridiquement
certains moyens d'action y compris celui
de modifier le contenu des ordonnances
au moment de la ratification ou même en
dehors de son processus normal reste
qu'il nous paraît essentiel aujourd'hui
de franchir un nouveau pas dans
l'association du Parlement au processus
d'élaboration des ordonnances sans pour
autant changer la donne
constitutionnelle mais en
perfectionnement les pratique existantes
j'ai au cours des auditions exploré deux
pistes à cet égard soit le projet
d'ordonnance fait l'objet d'une
consultation publique ouverte à tous et
le Parlement doit s voir reconnaître un
accès tout à fait privilégié soit aucune
consultation publique n'est organisée et
les commissions parlementaires doivent
être destinataires des projets
d'ordonnance afin donc d'émettre des
avis mais dans votre intervention madame
la ministre tout à l'heure vous avez été
tout à fait rassurante sur cette
question j'ajoute que partout en Europe
où la simplification progresse les les
parlements y sont associés de manière
tout à fait à fait étroite en second
lieu nous soulignons la nécessité de
respecter le rythme des réformes prévu
aux articles 18 et 19 du projet de loi
et si possible de l'accélérer en effet
si ce rythme n'est pas plus court que
celui de la procédure législative de
droit commun la raison d'être de
l'habilitation qui est de répondre à une
urgence économique en serait bien
entendu fragilisée je voudrais dans un
troisème temps rappeler les points
précis sur lesquels la commission des
affaires économiques a souhaité ins
je commencerai par évoquer les
amendements qui ont été intégrés dans le
texte issus des travaux de notre
commission des lois et qui nous sert de
base de discussion il concerne tout
d'abord le volet de l'article 3 consacré
au périmètre du régime des conventions
réglementé le projet de loi par souci de
simplicité vise à placer en dehors de ce
régime strict les conventions qui ne
présentent pas en principe de risque
d'abus il s'agit de celles qui sont par
exemple conclues entre une société mèire
et sa filiale à 100 % qui forme donc un
ensemble solidaire inversement la
Commission a souhaité renforcer les
moyens de contrôle des conventions
présentant un risque plus sérieux de
détournement l'article 10 quant à lui
prévoit la modernisation de la
gouvernance et la clarification
juridique de la gestion des
participations de l'État au terme d'une
analyse attentive j'en suis arrivé à
deux principales conclusions qui ont été
approuvées par la commission des
Affaires économique d'abord il nous a
semblé inopportun en dépit de la
précision insuffisante du dispositif de
cet article
de risquer d'entraver la tâche du
gouvernement en détaillant et en
compliquant le texte cette préférence
pour la simplicité ne conduit cependant
pas le législateur à signé une une sorte
de chèque en blanc puisque l'exposé des
motifs ainsi que les débats
parlementaires sont pris en compte par
le Conseil constitutionnel lorsqu'il
statue sur la précision de
l'habilitation or cet exposé des motif
reprend presque mot pour mot l'une des
principales recommandations faites par
notre commission à l'occasion de
l'examen des crédits de l'État
actionnaire il s'agit de donner à l'état
une plus grande souplesse de nomination
au sein des conseils d'administration et
de désigner des représentants de l'État
issus d'un vivier plus étendu
qu'aujourd'hui toutefois pour traduire
cette seule intention le gouvernement
devra modifier au moins quatre lois en
revanche la Commission a estimé
souhaitable plutôt que de rallonger le
texte de délimiter l'habilitation par
une borne très claire en précisant
qu'elle n'autorise pas le gouver ement a
diminuer le niveau de contrôle de l'État
actionnaire dans les entreprises
stratégiques relevant de son périmètre
ce point est d'ailleurs parfaitement
consensuel puisque l'article 10 a
effectivement pour objet la
clarification et la modernisation du
droit applicable aux participations de
l'État et non pas la modification des
sees de contrôle j'en viens à
l'amendement écarté pour des raisons
juridiques par la commission des lois et
que je vous présenterai dans la
discussion de l'article 1er il s'agit de
renforcer les garanties permettant de
s'assurer que la simplification de
certaines obligations des employeurs en
matière d'affichage s'effectuera
s'effectuera dans le strict respect des
droits des salariés et au terme d'une
procédure consultative sous l'égide du
Ministère en charge du travail pour la
commission des affaires économiques le
sens de cet amendement est avant tout
d'adresser un message général pour
rassurer les salariés en soulignant que
les mesures de simplification ne doivent
en aucun cas porter atteinte à leur
droit particulièrement leur droit
d'information j'en termine avec une
observation de droit comparé à la
simplification pour en venir à ma
conclusion nous devons à l'expérience
belge de simplification l'invention du
concept dites-le nous une fois qui a été
repris en France et qui mérite d'être
généralisé sur l'ensemble de nos
territoires je signale que nos voisins
pratiquent également ce qui est appelé
le test Cafka qui a été qualifié par la
Banque mondiale de particulièrement
novateur très concrètement ce test
permet d'évaluer l'impact d'une nouvelle
réglementation sur les charges
administratives à l'aide d'un
questionnaire précis sur le nombre et la
périodicité des formalités et
obligations induites par les normes
envisagées je me demande simplement si
ce test ne pourrait pas être incorporé
dans les études d'impact qui
accompagnent obligatoirement les projets
de loi depuis la dernière réforme de nos
institutions en fin de compte ce qui
nous frappe surtout dans ce projet de
loi c'est bien sûr ça nécessité nous
devons améliorer notre compétitivité
temp alléger la charge administrative à
la fois pour les entreprises et pour
l'État réduire le coût et la pénibilité
des traitements papiers et donc
clarifier notre droit quant au recours
aux ordonnances notre fibre
parlementaire nous conduit tout
naturellement à exprimer certaines
réserves je rappelle cependant que 331
ordonnances ont été publiées entre début
2005 et fin 2012 soit environ 41 par an
contre 21 en cette année 2013 à
l'évidence ces chiffres traduisent donc
plutôt un ralentissement contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait entendre ici ou là la
priorité est donc de faire face à
l'urgence économique à l'importance de
l'enjeu qui se chiffre à plus d'un point
de produit intérieur brut et à la
nécessité de rejoindre le pleloton de
tête des pays européens en matière de
simplification ces ordonnances madame la
ministre mes chers collègues vont y
contribuer et c'est pourquoi nous sommes
très favor
le
habilitation merci monsieur le
rapporteur dans la suite de la
discussion la parole est à Monsieur
François patriard rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des
finances monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission mesdames messieurs madames
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues à la demande du chef de l'État
le gouvernement a donc
engagé choc de
simplification nous savons tous il a été
rappelé à cette tribune avant moi
combien il est nécessaire combien il est
urgent mais combien nous souhaitons
cette fois-ci qu'il soit réellement
efficace une première loi en direction
des citoyens a été promulguée début
novembre le projet de loi que nous
examinons apportera des réponses cette
fois-ci aux préoccupations elles sont
nombreuses
elles sont urgentes elles sont
nécessaires les préoccupations des
entreprises je il me permet également de
souligner que l'œuvre de simplification
ne se limite pas seulement à sa
traduction législative parmi les 200
mesures de simplification adopté par le
comité interministériel pour la
modernisation de l'action publique
nombreuses sont celles qui relèvent du
pouvoir réglementaire parfois même
simplement de la simple circulaire
administrative je sais que la méthode du
recours aux ordonnances ça a été rappelé
par mes collègues avant moi suscite
toujours la polémique sur sur les bans
de notre assemblée parfois de ce côté
parfois de ce
côté c'est pourquoi en tant que
rapporteur au centre aussi ma cher
collègue c'est pourtant en tant que
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des finances et je sais que le
rapporteur au fond Yannick vrenard vient
de le faire aussi rapporteurs pour avis
ont adopté la même démarche c'est
pourquoi disais je me suis efforcé de
comprendre les intentions du
Gouvernement derrière chacune des
habilitations
demandé le résultat de ce travail
minutieux c'est la soixantaine
d'amendements exam iné mercredi dernier
par la commission des lois dont six
déposés par notre commission la
commission des finances les amendements
adoptés sont venus préciser circonscrire
détailler les habilitations le Sénat a
donc bien veillé à ce qu'elle ne soit
pas à
blanin nous devons conserver le même
degré de vigilance lors de la
ratification des ordonnances la
commission des finances est saisie de H
articles et saisi de articles sur le
projet de loi principalement dans le
domaine du droit bancaire et financier
la commission des lois nous a délégué au
fond l'examen des articles 11 12 15 et
21 s'agissant des articles que nous
avons examiné les articles 11 et 12
permettre de transposer des directives
européennes ou de mettre en cohérence le
droit français avec le règlement
européen il s'agit en particulier de
tirer les conséquences des des textes
dit crd4 sur le renforcement des fonds
promes des banques ou du Règlement sur
le mécanisme de supervision de unique de
l'Union bancaire ces textes européens
mett en uvre une régulation renforcée et
exigeante de la finance c'est un souci
de sécurité pour l'ensemble des
partenaires les entreprises mais aussi
les particuliers la France est a défendu
avec ardeur il serait donc regrettable
que nous tardions à les mettre en œuvre
le recours à la procédure par ordonnance
a donc paru tout à fait justifié puisque
les ordonnances sont aujourd'hui réelles
elles sont il non puisque les textes
sont maintenant ratifiés et bien il nous
faut les mettre en place très vite dans
notre pays les articles 15 et 21 ratifie
les ordonnances également dans le
domaine financier pris sur le fondement
d'habilitation voté par le Parlement
dans le cadre de la loi qui a créé la
banque publique d'investissement nous
avons également examiné les dispositions
de l'article 1er relative à
l'encadrement financier
participatif ce mode de financement par
Internet est encore balbuciant mais nous
savons qu'il est en plein essor et dans
d'autres pays il est déjà beaucoup plus
développé madame la ministre vous savez
bien de quoi je parle quand on parle du
crowdfunding il importe d'accompagner le
développement du financement
participatif en lui donnant dès à
présent un cadre juridique solide qui
rassure à la fois les professionnels et
les internautes qui investissent enfin
la Commission a examiné les dispositions
de l'article 3 sur le régime des valeurs
mobilières complexes de l'article 9 sur
les modités sur les modalités de
reporting social et environnemental des
mutuels et des établissements de crédit
et enfin l'article 10 sur la
modernisation de l'État actionnaire les
amendements que nous avons proposés ont
tous été adoptés par la commission des
lois monsieur le Président je vous en
remercie au total notre commission s
proposé s prononcé favorablement
d'ailleurs pratiquement l'unanimité pour
l'adaption de ce texte dont nous savons
qu'il est attendu par de nombreuses
entreprises je vous
remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Esther ben
Bassa
je crois qu'il y avait
quelqu monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre monsieur le rapporteur madamees
messieurs les rapporteurs pour avis mes
chers
collègues le présent projet de loi
procède de ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler le choc de simplification
engagé par le gouvernement en effet
comme le rappelle l'exposé des motifs la
commission européenne estime qu'une
réduction de 25 % des charges
administratives des entreprises
augmenterait le PIB de 0,8 % à court
terme et de 1,4 % à plus long terme
au niveau national cette réduction
pourrait engendrer des économies de
l'ordre de 15 milliards d'euros pour les
entreprises l'objectif est alors de
prendre des mesures permettant aux
entreprises de se libérer de certaines
tâches administratives pouvant être
modernisé de se concentrer sur le cœur
de leur activité mais avant de revenir
sur le fond de ce projet de loi qui
contient de nombreuses mesures de
différents ordres il me semble important
de de revenir sur la forme en effet le
choix par le gouvernement de recourir
aux ordonnances prévues par l'article 38
de notre Constitution n'est pas sans
poser de questions au groupe écologiste
il est sans doute à la fois pertinent et
urgent d'améliorer l'environnement
législatif des entreprises mais en tant
que parlementaire nous regrettons
toujours de ne pas pouvoir débattre plus
sereinement de chaque mesure elles sont
ici très
nombreuses de sur de sur croix ce projet
de loi qui traite aussi bien des
obligations comptables des très petites
entreprises que de droit du travail est
débattu dans un temps encore limité par
le recours à la procédure
accélérée nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale ont contesté ce mode d'examen
d'un projet de loi important pour la vie
de nos entreprises je veux dire ici que
le groupe écologiste partage
l'intégralité de ses
préoccupations nous avons toutefois
entendu l'engagement du gouvernement
pris à l'Assemblée nationale par votre
intermédiaire madame la ministre
d'associer les parlementaires aux
travaux qui
conduiront à la publication des
ordonnances prévues par ce texte
engagement qui avait déjà été pris par
Madame Marie-Lise Lebranchu lors de
l'examen du projet de loi d'habilitation
relative à la simplification des
relations entre les citoyens et
l'administration et dont nous attendons
qu'il soit respecté mais revenons au
fond du projet de loi d'habilitation que
nous examinons aujourd'hui il comporte
21 articles qui concernent des sujets
aussi divers que la simplification de
100 de certaines démarches
administratives ou comptables des
entreprises la révision du droit des des
entreprises en difficulté le
développement du projet du Grand Paris
ou encore le développement de certains
secteurs et professions comme les
notaires et les experts comptables sur
cet ensemble relativement hétéroclite
deux séries de mesures sont
particulièrement importantes aux yeux
des écologistes tout d'abord l'article
14 qui habilite le gouvernement à
expérimenter dans un nombre limité de
régions et pour une durée n'excédant pas
3 ans une procédure unique intégrée
conduisant à une décision unique du
préfet de département concernant les
installation classée pour la protection
de l'environnement ICPE est soumise à
autorisation cette expérimentation
prendrait deux formes différentes selon
qu'ell concernent certaines
installations de production d'énergie
renouvelable comme éolienne installation
de méthanisation et cetera ou ou les
autres installations classées
l'objectif affiché d'accélérer la
totalité des procédures qui pourrai être
enséré dans un délai réglementaire qu'il
est en qu'il est envisagé de réduire à
10 mois pour les éoliennes les
écologistes considèrent qu'il s'agit à
priori d'une mesure intéressante qui va
dans le sens de la simplification limite
les opportunités de recours et devrait
Infiné permettre de réduire les délais
d'instruction nous appelons depuis
longtemps la révision des procédures
pour que la durée de mise en service des
éoliennes en France se rapproche de
celle de nos voisins européens nous nous
félicitons également des simplifications
annoncées concernant les les
installations de méthanisation ces
dernières étant sans aucun doute l'une
des réponses d'avenir pour la production
d'énergie renouvelable et la
décentralisation de la production
d'énergie
ensuite l'article 16
qui modifie dans la version initiale du
texte la rédaction du 2e alinéa de
l'article L
541-10-5 du code de l'environnement afin
de reporter du 1er janvier 2012 au 1er
janvier 2015 la date à compter de
laquelle tout produit recyclable soumis
à un dispositif de responsabilité
élargie des producteurs doit faire
l'objet d'une signalétiique commune à
savoir la position d'un logo de tri
appelé trimment informant le
consommateur que ce produit relève d'une
consigne de
tri si nous regrettons ce report nous
rappelons avec force la nécessité de la
mise en place d'une telle signaléthtique
pour améliorer les performances en
matière en matière de recyclage il est
certain que cette mesure aura pour effet
d'accroitre la quantité de produits
recyclés et permettra de diminuer
l'utilisation de matières premières non
renouvelables c'est la raison pour
laquelle je défendrai un un amendement
visant à rétablir l'article 16 dans sa
rédaction initiale finalement et malgré
les réserves que j'ai émises concernant
les modalités d'examen le groupe
écologiste conscient des avancées
concrètes que ce projet de loi permettra
votera pour ce texte je vous en remercie
merci Madame
bembassa dans la suite de la discussion
la parole est à Monsieur André richchard
richchard
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues c'est un fait les
réglementations pesant sur les
entreprises de notre pays dont 99 % sont
des PME ou des TPE sont toujours plus
nombreuses et
contraignantes nous sommes tous d'accord
ici du moins je le crois sur ce constat
d'une complexité administrative et
juridique fortement dommageable à la vie
économique je dirais même à la
nécessaire respiration économique de
notre pays
d'ors il est évident que toute volonté
de simplifier et de sécuriser la vie des
entreprises s'inscrit a priori dans un
objectif éminemment louable voire
salutaire pour autant la question qui se
pose ici est de savoir si tant sur la
forme que sur le fond le projet de loi
d'habilitation à prendre par ordonnance
diverses mesures de simplification et de
sécurisation de la vie des entreprises
tel qu'il nous est soumis répond bien à
cet objectif et est à même de faire
vreutile sur la forme tout d'abord le
gouvernement a choisi de recourir aux
ordonnances prévues par l'article 38 de
la
Constitution c'est en 18 mois le 3è
texte de la législature faisant usage de
cette procédure après la loi du 1er
juillet 2013 habilitant le gouvernement
à adopter des mesures de nature
législative pour accélérer les
constructions de logements et le projet
de loi en cours d'examen habilitant le
gouvernement à simplifier les relations
entre l'administration et les
citoyens bien entendu puisqu'elle est
prévue par la
Constitution l'utilisation des
ordonnances n'est pas en elle-même
contestable pourtant permettez-moi moi
en premier lieu de m'interroger sur
cette appétence récente pour cette
procédure dès alors que sous d'autres
gouvernements l'opposition n'avait pas
de mot assez dur pour décrier cette même
méthode pour mettre pencher sur les
travaux qui ont eu lieu sur ce projet de
loi à l'Assemblée nationale je note
d'ailleurs que tant le rapporteur
socialiste de la commission des lois que
le rapporteur socialiste lui aussi de la
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire se sont
interrogés de la même façon sur je cite
le risque de dérive de ce recours aux
ordonnances qui constitue je cite
toujours un sujet délicat toujours
inconfortable pour les
parlementaires d'autant plus contestable
ici je cite encore qu'un exercice de
simplification n'est jamais dénué de
risque et qui suscite dernière citation
des réserves de la part des deux
rapporteurs
précidés pour toute dérive monsieur le
rapporteur de la commission des lois à
l'Assemblée nationale a ainsi été d'avis
de soumettre à l'avenir ce recours aux
ordonnances au respect de deux types de
conditions tout d'abord que le
gouvernement indique avec précision la
finalité des mesures qu'il se propose de
prendre par voie d'ordonnance que
l'habilitation soit temporaire et
qu'elle soit encadrée par un délai
limite condition qui me paraissent posé
par la Constitution elle-même en second
lieu
la deuxème condition serait que le
recours aux ordonnances soit justifié
par l'urgence des mesures à adopter et
par leur
technicité voyons donc si vous le voulez
bien après notre éminent collègue de
l'Assemblée ce qu'il en est de ces deux
conditions s'agissant de l'urgence il
faut noter que ce texte fait l'objet de
la procédure accélérée et celle-ci
pourrait effectivement elle seule
accréditer cette thèse de la nécessité
de légiférer rapidement dans les
dossiers concernés mais cet argument
vous le savez bien mes chers collègues
ne tient pas tant nous avons pris
l'habitude ici d'examiner des textes en
procédure accéléré et de fait force de
constater que dans un nombre des
dispositions un grand nombre des
dispositions concernées voire la
totalité l'urgence n'existe pas
permettez-moi ainsi à titre d'exemple de
m'interroger à la suite du rapporteur de
l'Assemblée nationale dont je parlais
sur l'urgence de procéder par ordonnance
lorsque le projet de loi prévoit un
délai d'habilitation de 12 mois ce qui
est le cas de l'article
12 si le gouvernement se donne un an à
compter de la publication de la présente
loi pour adopter l'ordonnance ce délai
n'aurait-il pas permis de procéder par
voie législative
ordinaire d'ailleurs sans vouloir
insister plus longuement sur son plan
sur ce plan quelle urgence peut-il
bienoir d'instituer le salariat pour les
avocats au Conseil d'État et à la Cour
de cassation article 5 ou encore
d'augmenter le nombre de notaires
salariés dans les offices natariales
article
4 puis vient la deuxème condition
relative à la définition de la précision
avec laquelle le périmètre
d'intervention du gouvernement doit être
borné sur ce plan disons-le nettement
dans ce texte d'habilitation tel qu'il
nous a été soumis le champ
d'intervention du gouvernement est bien
trop souvent bien trop imprécis pour que
le Parlement exerce effectivement son
pouvoir d'appréciation conformément à
l'article 38 de la Constitution même si
madame la ministre vient de nous dire
que le Parlement serait associé à
l'élaboration des ordonnances ainsi à
titre d'exemple en matière d'aménagement
du territoire l'alinéa 2 de l'article
13 autorise le représentant de l'État
dans le département a délivré à titre
expérimental je cite au porteur de
projet dont la mise en œuvre et soumise
à certaines autorisations
administratives relevant de sa
compétence régie par les dispositions du
code de l'environnement du code
forestier ou du Code de l'Urbanisme un
document dénommé certificat de projet or
aucun critère législatif d'octroi de ce
certificat de projet n'est défini par le
texte ce qui légitime
fait redouter des choix arbitraires à
l'avenir de même à l'article 11 où un
amendement du Gouvernement a été adopté
afin de réformer les modalités de calcul
et d'application du taux d'intérêt légal
force de constater que les modalités de
calcul de ce nouveau taux d'intérêt
légal sont flous ce que le ministre a
d'ailleurs avoué lors de la discussion
de ce texte à l'Assemblée nationale en
précisant j'ouvre les guillemets que les
consultations sur ce point ne sont pas
tout à fait fait achev et que dire de
l'article 14 qui crée à titre
expérimental une procédure unique
intégré pour autoriser la construction
d'installation classé IPCE qui bénéficie
principalement aux
éoliens cette proposition fait écho à la
PPL Brod dont mes chers collègues vous
vous souvenez qui voulait assouplir
l'implantation des éolienne terrestre et
offshore dans les zones littorales
assouplissement auquels c'était op le
Sénat on le sait bien mes chers
collègues tout assouplissement des
mesures concernant l'implantation des
éoliennes suscite de nombreuses
interrogations notamment au regard du
patrimoine naturel et et de
l'aménagement du territoire et il faut
donc être très vigilant à cet
égard on pourrait sur ce plan multiplier
les exemples d'imprécision de l'action
future du gouvernement dans les
ordonnances qu'il envisage de
prendre d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre rapporteur de la
commission des lois Monsieur Mohamed
swalii a en réunion de commission et il
nous l'a redit tout à l'heure proposer
différents amendements visant à
améliorer le texte à cet égard et dont
on verra le sort en séance tout à
l'heure mais quitt Tom maintenant les
questions de forme pour en venir au
fond ce projet de loi d'habilitation
répondtil aux objectifs de
simplification et de sécurisation de la
vie des
entreprises
en premier lieu le moins que l'on puisse
dire est qu'il j'ouvre les guillemets
souffre d'une grande hétérogénéité de
ses dispositions comme dit le rapporteur
de la commission des lois à l'Assemblée
nationale celui-ci déplore ainsi à juste
titre selon moi j'ouvre les guillemet
qu'il manque de cohérence dans ces
dispositions et qu'il comporte de trop
nombreuses dispositions ne relevant pas
de la vie des entreprises
CC il ajoute d'ailleurs que si les
habilitations proposées sur les sur ces
derniers sujets sont certes utiles et
justifié leur insertion dans le présent
projet de loi affaiblit sa cohérence et
sa sa lisibilité et je ferme les
guillemets enfin dernière citation et
c'est la meilleure le caractère
hétéroclite du texte va sans doute
s'accroître à l'issue de nos travaux
cont tenu des amendements divers et
variés déposés par le gouvernement qui
portent sur des sujets aussi variés
que la caisse commune de sécurité
sociale de la lozer le mode de calcul du
taux d'intérêt légal ou le cadre
juridique de la gestion d'actifs je
ferme les
guillumet et de fait nous y sommes bien
arrivés ce projet de loi constitue
désormais un véritable
patchwork qui comprend certes des
dispositions de nature à simplifier la
vue des entreprises d'autres qui n'ont
rien à voir avec cette simplification et
d'autres enfin qui vont bien au-delà de
la seule
simplification s'agissant des
dispositions sans lien avec la vie des
entreprise on ne peut que regretter et
dénoncer le fait qu'elle figure dans un
texte d'habilitation d'une part et
qu'ell rate leur cible d'autre part
c'est le cas des articles 5 8 11 et
d'autres et je ne sais pas quel est le
grief le
pire par contre les mesures qui
dépassent la simplification concernent
des sujets d' importance dont le
Parlement cela a été dit tout à l'heure
devrait être saisi dans un travail
législatif normal et qui devrait faire
l'objet d'un vrai débat c'est le cas
particulièrement de l'article 2 qui
réécrit presque totalement ça a été dit
tout à l'heure le droit des entreprises
en difficulté ou encore et c'est
toujours monsieur le rapporteur pour la
pour avis de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire à
l'Assemblée nationale qui le dit
l'article 10 relatif au renforcement
dans la gestion des participations de
l'État ou encore les articles 11 et 12
concernant la mise en œuvre du droit de
l'Union
européenne force est de constater que de
telles questions n'ont pas leur place
dans un projet de loi de
simplification en procédant ainsi par
ordonnance vous privez les
parlementaires de tout contrôle sur ces
mesures qui de toute évidence outrepasse
le cadre strict d'une entreprise de
simple ication mes chers collègues ces
paroles ne sont pas les miennes ce sont
celles du rapporteur socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale précité je n'ai
rien à leur ajouter pour notre part au
groupe UMP nous sommes d'avis qu'il
aurait été plus opportun que le
Parlement soit étroitement associé à la
définition de toutes ces dispositions
afin de proposer de véritables mesures
susceptible de simplifier et sécuriser
la vie des entreprises comme c'est le
cas par exemple au Royaume-Uni et au
Pays-Bas où le rôle du Parlement a été
renforcé dans le domaine de la
simplification avec la création de
commissions
spécifique de fait de nombreuses
simplifications nécessaires ont
simplement été oubliées par ce texte je
pense ainsi à la récurrente
problématique du bulletin de paye dont
on sait qu'il se complexifie lors de
chaque mesure sociale nouvelle je pense
également à la réglementation de la
création d'entreprise qui reste
particulièrement lourde alors même que
l'on aurait pu ici s'inspirer de celle
qui régit auto-entrepreneur et de façon
générale réfléchir aux modalités
d'alignement du fonctionnement de
beaucoup de PME sur ce dernier régime
dont la souplesse est reconnue par
beaucoup de même ce texte fait l'impasse
sur la nécessaire simplification du Code
du travail don les plus de 10000
articles sont trop souvent inadaptés à
la réalité du fonctionnement actuel des
TPE et des PME on aurait ainsi pu
réfléchir à un lissage des seuils
d'effectifs au-delà duquel des règles
spécifiques s'imposent à l'entreprise et
freine on le sait bien son initiative en
terme d'embauche manque également des
dispositions tout aussi urgentes
destinées à faciliter l'accès de nos PME
aux marchés publics sur le modèle du
Small Business Act américain mes chers
collègues répondre à un appel d'offre
n'est pas chose facile pour des petites
entreprises et il serait utile
d'améliorer rapidement la situation sur
ce plan enfin et particulièrement dans
les circonstances économiques actuelles
il aurait fallu réfléchir à nouveau à
l'urgente simplification du crédit
d'impôt compétitivité
emploi le C le cice voulu comme une
importante mesure de soutien à la
compétitivité des entreprises par le
gouvernement s'est effectivement avéré
jusqu'ici trop complexe et trop
alliatoire dans les retours concrets
qu'il offrent aux entreprises alors
qu'une simple diminution des charges
aurait suffi et aurait à notre sens été
plus efficace
Infiné monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues alors que
le gouvernement a annoncé vouloir
provoquer un choc de
simplification pour le groupe UMP ce Tex
ne prend pas les vraies mesures
attendues par les professionnels qui
leur simplifieraient la vie au quotidien
et leur permettrai de gagner en
compétitivité il s'agit au contraire
d'un texte confus et complexe
excusez-moi de le dire comme ça presque
à l'opposé de sa volonté de
simplification et qui ne nous paraît pas
pouvoir favoriser la croissance c'est en
conclusion pour nous une occasion ratée
d'un véritable rendez-vous que nous
aurions pu avoir avec les entreprises
sur la simplification je vous remercie
de votre
attention merci Monsieur richchard dans
la suite de la discussion la parole est
à Monsieur em de
montesquio
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président Monsieur les rapporteurs il
n'est pas dans la tradition
parlementaire de promouvoir les
ordonnances mais l'urgence d'agir et la
technicité de la matière peuvent vaincre
les réticences
parlementaire ainsi les socialistes sont
systématiquement et vigoureusement
opposés à toutes les ordonnances entre
2002 et 2012 mais chacun peut évoluer
autre temps autre murs pour nous tous le
recours aux ordonnances pour simplifier
et sécuriser la vie des entreprises a
pour objectif d'aller à la fois le
pragmatisme et la rapidité dans ce
domaine essentiel l'intitulé de ce ce
projet de loi répond aux préoccupations
des entreprises il répond aux alertes
récurrentes des parlementaires de l'UDI
si vous nous
proposez une recherche commune de
l'efficacité nous serons partenaires
dans le cas contraire ce sera une
occasion ratée et ce serait dommage pour
notre pays si notre temps ne doit jamais
se consacrer à de veines querelles
doctrinales il doit encore moins s'y
perdre aujourd'hui car il y a urgence
pour notre économie l'enjeu est crucial
pour développer notre potentiel de
croissance cette simplification pourrait
accroître selon les estimations
concordantes 1,4 % de PIB de l'Union
européenne et comme l'a rapporté madame
Bassa générer 15 milliards d'euros
d'économies annuelles pour nos
entreprises cela engendrerait un plan de
lance enfin parfaitement neutre pour nos
finances publiques avec pour seul
investissement le bon
sens chaque gouvernement toute couleur
confondue chaque législateur
empile frénétiquement de nouvelles
réglementation la lutte contre
l'inflation normative pronée par le
couple Lambert Boulard constitue une
urgence une mission d'intérêt public je
fais bien leur constat L qu'il déclare
qu'il en a des normes comme du poivre et
du sel leur absence comme leur excès
rend le tout
inconsommable nous savons bien combien
il est difficile de simplifier le droit
Madame le Ministre les paquets varsman
ont occupé une part de nos travaux pour
un bilan très mitigé l'intention a étit
bonne le résultat n'a pas été à la
hauteur de nos espérances et de nos
ambitions le droit applicable aux
entreprises reste terriblement et
beaucoup trop complexe une vie le
trpiste ne suffirait pas pour assimiler
le code du travail et le code des impôts
leur illisible complexité décourage
beaucoup de candidats entrepreneurs et
auerre la vie des entreprises en
consommant de longues heures qui devrai
être utilisé à la créativité et à la
gestion quelle est la problématique de
base fonderner son entreprise est un
défi à la patience et à la punacité
laffaire prospérer est une tâche encore
plus exigeante les effets de seuil sont
dévastateurs la concurrence étrangère
rude les sessions d'entreprisees posent
problème puisque de nombreuses
entreprises familiales sont obligées de
se scinder pour contourner une fiscalité
prohibitive j'ajoute que plus du tiers
des entreprises ne survisent pas aux
cinq premières années d'activité cette
question est récurrente notamment
lorsqu'on compare notre tissu industriel
à celui de l'Allemagne riche et forte de
ces entreprises de taille intermédiaire
est devenu des références en matière
d'exportation le président de la
République s'est engagé à provoquer un
choc de simplification le Premier
ministre a commandé un rapport sur la
simplification de l'environnement
réglementaire et fiscal des entreprises
le rapport du député Thierry Mandon qui
est de qualité a été élaboré dans une
démarche collaborative en concertation
avec les entreprises pour identifier
leurs difficultés et leurs besoins et
cet inspiré d'expériences étrangères
madame la ministre vous aviez là une
base précieuse pour mener un travail de
fond sur la simplification de la vie des
entreprises des propositions claires
organisées pragmatiques et pertinente
combien en avez-vous retenu l'objectif
de ce projet de loi celui de relancer la
compétitivité de nos entreprises pour
qu'ell se consacre au cœur de l'
activité est
essentiel comment ne pas totalement
souscrire à la suppression de certaines
obligations des entreprises formulées
dans l'article 1er alléger les
obligations comptables des PME et TPE
généraliser la facture électronique
simplifier les procédures par le projet
dites-le nous qu'une fois et favoriser
le financement participatif
votre projet de loi se serait concentré
sur ces
dispositions qui sont consacré aux
entreprise PME et TPE en priorité vous
auriez eu notre soutien total hélas
pourquoi ce texte regroupe-t-il un
ensemble hétérogène qui correspond si
peu à l'intitulé du projet de loi de
plus son manque d'ambition constitue un
renoncement il ne peut constituer un
inventaire de disposition sectoriel
partiel je prends quelques exemples la
création du statut d'avocat au Conseil
salariés ou l'augmentation du nombre de
notaires salariés est-ce une prioritaire
pour la simplification les dispositions
de l'article 14 sur les éoliennes ou le
biogaz ont-elles leur place dans ce
projet de loi plutôt que dans le projet
de loi attendu sur la transition
énergétique l'article 16 prévoyait
d'opposer le logo triman sur tous les
emballages recyclables c'est une bonne
idée mais y inclureant le verre qui a
son cycle propre n'est-il pas
contreproductif et coûteux le groupe udi
a déposé un amendement pour en exclure
autre exemple l'article 11 vise la
transposition des directives ficode crd4
et CRR par voie d'ordonnance cette
transposition des normes prudentielles
de bal 3 est très importante leur impact
sur le système bancaire est est majeur
elle a été débatue lors de la discussion
de la loi de séparation et de régulation
bancaire l'article 12 vise la mise en
conformité de la législation avec le
mécanisme de supervision unique du
secteur bancaire par la BCE ces
dispositions n'auraient-elles pas mérité
un examen parlementaire plus approfondi
j'insiste ces dispositions
n'auraiit-elle pas nécessité quelques
heures de débat en séance plutôt qu'une
poignée de minutes volé détour d'une
prise de parole sur l'article madame la
ministre vous demandez au Parlement de
vous habiliter à légiférer soit mais
pour mais nous vous demandons en retour
de faire confiance au Parlement et
notamment au Sénat il est encore temps
de préciser le contenu de vos
habitations ou du moins de nous informer
plus précisément sur vos intentions sur
sans cette information la ratification
des ordonnances restera un exercice
formel et il reviendra finalement au
Conseil constitutionnel de contrôler la
qualité de vos décisions on cherche la
cohérence de ce texte que vous nous
proposez c'est un texte hybride qui mèle
à la fois des habilitations à légiféré
par ordonnance des dispositions
législatives des transpositions de
directive des ratification d'ordonnance
c'est trop vous auriez pu Madame le
Ministre organiser un cycle de consult
avec les parlementaires afin de nous
associer à la définition de l'objectif
assigné à ces ordonnances il en a rien
été d'examen très serré à l'Assemblée
nous ont à peine permis de prendre
connaissance de vos intention la bonne
pratique du gouvernement Jospin
d'accompagner la demande d'habilitation
des projets d'ordonnance eux-mêmes est
aujourd'hui tombé en D
suétude votre texte n'est pas adapté ce
projet de loi je le répète sans
cohérence dans la forme discutable dans
la méthode et pas au niveau de l'enjeu
auquel il prétend répondre ne peut
emporter l'adhésion des membres du
groupe udi et vraiment je le
regrette merci Monsieur Emer de
montescuot la parole est à Madame
elliane
Assassi
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues le texte donc que nous
examinons aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans le
cadre du choc de simplification qui a
donc été annoncé en mars dernier par le
Président de la République et il entend
mettre en œuvre le programme triénal de
simplification de la vie des entreprises
alors vous savez le choix des mots n'est
pas innocent et donc nous n'avons été
guerre surpris par la teneur de ce texte
qui s' inscrit largement dans la lignée
des textes de simplification ou
d'allègement de la législature
précédente si le rapporteur de la
commission des lois à l'Assemblée
nationale précise à cet égard je le cite
que conformément au souhait du président
de la République le Gouvernement a
engager un nouveau processus de
simplification qui tire les leçons des
dysfonctionnements constatés sous la
présente précédente
législature nous
constatons ainsi ou aussi que la
modernisation de l'action publque la
fameuse map n'est en fait qu'une
nouvelle version de la révision générale
des politiques publiques dès lors vous
comprendrez que le recours massif aux
ordonnances de l'article 38 l'absence de
justification par l'urgence
l'habilitation demandé sur un contenu
large et évasif nous conduis à émettre
puisque nous sommes toujours cohérents
les mêmes critiques qu'hier il est vrai
que le texte comporte à un nombre
raisonnable d'articles mais il procède
trop souvent à des regrou regoupement
anarchique de sujets divers au sein d'un
même article à cela s'ajoute que le
contenu des dispositions s'éloigne de la
simple de la seule simplification de la
vie des entreprises il en va ainsi du
régime de participation des employeur à
l'effort de construction sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs le Parlement a adopté en
juillet dernier une loi habilitant le
gouvernement à prendre des mesures de
nature législative pour accélérer les
projets de construction rien ne justif
non plus les articles 12 et 13 qui pent
habilitation pour transposer les
recommandations bal 3 ou le mécanisme de
surveillance unique ce débat doit avoir
lieu devant le Parlement et non rester
calfetré dans les bureaux de la
Commission européenne ou du ministère
des Finances au-delà du lien bien tenu
de certaines dispositions avec le sujet
annoncé ce projet de loi se caractérise
également par des occasions manquées
c'est le cas de l'article 16 qui après
une réécriture par un amendement de
l'opposition en commission a été
complètement vidé de son contenu c'est
le cas aussi de l'article 12 qui
autorise le gouvernement à réformer les
procédures relatives au traitement des
entreprises en difficulté par voie
d'ordonnance et qui prévoit de donner
compétenence au gouvernement pour
modifier le titre 6 du code commerce
relative aux entreprises en difficulté
notamment sur les questions du du régime
procédural pour notre part madame la
ministre nous attendions un projet de
loi qui réforme la justice consulaire
afin de mettre un terme aux situations
de conflit d'intérêt au sein même de
l'institution judiciaire enfin ce projet
de loi entend désaisir le pouvoir
législatif dans des domaines
particulièrement sensibles dans un
contexte économique où le marché impose
sa loi faisant du travail sa variable
d'ajustement ainsi il nous est demandé
d'habiliter le gouvernement à modifier
le droit du travail tout en précisant
pour nous rassurer bien évidemment que
les partenaires sociaux ser ont associé
alors vous savez après le projet de loi
sur la ni à l'heure où le gouvernement
annonce son intention de supprimer les
élections prudomales vous comprendrez
que nous ne soyons pas enclins à donner
au pouvoir réglementairire le soin de
réformer les obligations faites aux
employeurs en matière d'affichage et de
transmission de documents à
l'administration de plus dans un
contexte de crise social de remise en
cause du Code du travail les salariés
nous semble-t-il ont besoin d'une
inspection forte et indépendante et non
pas d'une réforme par le bas des droits
existants la simple mise à disposition
des information prévu à l'article 1er
risque d'entraîner une moindre détection
des irrégularités par l'administration
en ce qui concerne l'habilitation pour
réformer le délai de prévenance vous
prévoyez de raccourcir ce délai afin
qu'il ne prolonge pas la période
d'cès cette modification risque de
pénaliser les salariés il n'est pas
àodin que les députés socialiste et
voter un amendement de la droite visant
à préciser que les modifications se
feront également dans l'intérêt des
employeurs et non plus seulement des
salariés l'article 14 ne nous satisfait
pas non plus nous avons eu le débat sur
la libéralisation de l'implantation des
éoliennes lors de l'examen de la loi
visant à préparer la la transition la
transition vers un système énergétique
sobre et portant diverses dispositions
sur la tarification de l'eau et sur les
la procédure unique intégrée
expérimentée pour les installations
classées pour la protection de
l'environnement vise à favoriser
l'industrie éolienne pour nous il est
important d'associer les populations
locales à de tels projets comme il est
fondamental d'avoir une réelle cohérence
de la politique énergétique et du mix
énergétique sur l'ensemble du territoire
l'article 10 quant à lui qui prévoit
d'autoriser le gouvernement à prendre
par ordonnance toute mesure mesure
visant à moderniser la gouvernance des
entreprises dans lesquelles l'État
détient une participation majoritaire ou
ou minoritaire il il il s'agit il
s'agira enfin àin il oh il convient
s'agit pour cela d'améliorer
l'efficacité et la souplesse de la
gestion de ces participations justifié
par la volonté de simplification il
n'est pas fait là encore pour nous
rassurer le projet d'ordonnance ne nous
a pas été présenté et en l'état le champ
de l'habilitation est particulièrement
large alors on tente également de nous
convaincre en renvoyant en renvoyant à
l'exposé des motifs que les ordonnances
préserveront pleinement la spécificité
de la représentation des salariés au
sein des entreprises publiques alors
j'ai une question pourquoi ne pas
l'avoir écrit dans l'article 10 ou dans
l'amendement que vous avez déposé pour
la séance sur cet article ensuite la
volonté de rapprochement des entreprises
visées avec celle du secteur privé n'est
pas acceptable pour nous un amendement à
l'initiative de la Commission des
affaires économiques précise je cite
pour les règles concernant les
opérations en capital que le
gouvernement n'aura pas l'habilitation
pour modifier des dispositions
particulières imposant un seuil minimum
de détention du capital de certaines de
ses entreprises par l'État ou ses
établissements publics alors cette
précision est très utile et elle montre
que les inquiétudes sont partagées
ensuite nous ne voyons pas l'intérêt de
modifier le recrutement des
administrateurs qui représentent l'état
dans ces entreprises ni la recherche de
talent ne le justifie et le risque de
conflit d'intérêt devrait l'interdire
nous considérons que ces entreprises
dans lesquelles l'État détient une part
du capital ne doivent pas être assimilé
à des entreprises du secteur privé elles
sont avant tout propriété de la nation
il y a quelques mois Arnaud mondbourg
déclaré dans une interview au Wall
Street Journal je cite dans le cadre de
la restructuration budgétaire et la
modernisation des politiques publiques
nous réfléchissons en effet à un
changement de nos
participations fin de citation il serait
inacceptable de brader une partie du
patrimoine de l'État pour répondre à des
politiques d'austérité là où l'intérêt
général appelle une consolidation de la
présence de l'État nous pensons pour
notre part qu'il est urgent de
renationaliser des outils industriels
stratégiques je pense en particulier au
secteur énergétique comme il est
nécessaire d'assurer une gouvernance qui
garantisse la démocratisation et
l'appropriation sociale des choix
stratégique et de la gestion des
entreprises enfin j'exprime à nouveau
ici notre vive inquiétude quant à la
régression des droits du Parlement le
projet de loi en est un exemple presque
complet recours massif aux ordonnances
urgence déclaré amendement du
Gouvernement portant article additionnel
examin examiné en commission sans examen
à l'Assemblée nationale à cela s'ajoute
d'autres verrous dont il est fait une
application gélée l'article 40 argument
tiré la transposition maximum d'actes
européens vote bloqué et nous avons même
vu lors de l'examen du projet de loi
relatif à la consommation le Sénat
adoptant un amendement sous réserve de
la décision de la Commission européenne
mes chers collègues vous comprendrez que
face à de tes GF tant sur la forme qui
devient pour le coup une question de
fond qu'en raison de l'importance et de
la diversité des sujets couverts par
l'habilitation l'appréciation du groupe
CRC soit plus que
réservé merci Madame
iassass la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Claude
requier monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues il y a un peu plus d'un
an le gouvernement présenta son Pact
national pour la croissance la
compétitivité et
l'emploi inspiré des conclusions de
l'excellent rapport Gallois depuis la
mesure phare de ce Pact le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi a été mis
en œuvre et commence à produire ses
effets positifs sur l'emploi et la
compétitivité la banque publique
d'investissement a également été mise en
place pour faciliter l'accès au
financement des TPE et des PME mais le
pacte de compétitivité prévoyait
également d'engager CIN chantiers de
iification des démarches des entreprises
le plus emblématique et sans doute
l'application du principe ditesle nous
une seule fois ou dites-le nous qu'une
fois qui vise à éviter que les
entreprises nent à fournir à de
multiples reprises les mêmes
informations à différentes
administrations plus de métiers moins de
papierers vous avez déclaré Mame
ministre je dirais plus de métiers plus
de chantier et moins de papierers dans
la continuité de ce pacte dont les
propositions ont été complétées par le
rapport du député Thierry Mandon et par
des mesures annoncé dans le cadre du
comité
interministériel pour la modernisation
de l'action publique du 17 juillet
dernier nous examinons aujourd'hui un
projet de loi qui vise à habiliter le
gouvernement à prendre par ordonnance
certaines mesures pour simplifier et
sécuriser la vie des entreprises comme
tout parlementaire responsable les
membres du RDSE ne sont Guer enclins à
autoriser la multiplication des
habilitations à légiféré par les
actuelles ordonnances auautre fois
c'était les décrets loi toutefois nous
sommes conscients de la nécessité dans
le domaine qui nous intéresse d'agir
vite et avec précision quelques mois de
gagner peuvent être vitaux pour le
développement voire pour la survie de
certaines entreprises c'est pourquoi
nous soutenons la plupart des articles
de ce projet de loi qui répondent bien à
l'objectif de simplification et de
sécurisation et sont donc attendus par
les entreprise l'article 1er qui
comporte un certain nombre
d'habilitations portant sur les sujet et
certainement l'un des plus importants il
prévoit notamment que les
micro-entreprises c'est-à-dire celles
qui compte moins de 10 salariés et
réalise un chiffre d'affaires net
inférieur à 700000 € et qui représente
je le rappelle 80 % du tissu
d'entreprise français pourront être
exemptés de l'obligation d'établir une
annexe au compte annuel et de
l'obligation de publier leur compte
annuel par contre l'obligation de
déposer leur compte est maintenue à
juste titre il est également prévu de
simplifier
les obligations comptables des
micro-entreprises et des petites
entreprises en les autorisant à établir
un bilan et un compte de résultat
abrégés dès lors près de 97 % des
sociétés commerciales seront concernés
par ces mesures de simplification qui
auront donc un effet positif sur notre
économie l'obligation de facturation
électronique entre les personnes
publiques leurs fournisseurs porte
également en elle une mesure de
simplification importante toutefois elle
peut présenter difficult pour les
petites entreprises c'est pourquoi je me
réjouis de de l'adoption d'un amendement
du rapporteur en commission qui prévoit
l'entrée en vigueur prog de cette mesure
afin de tenir compte je cite de la
taille et des capacités des entreprises
concernées le texte prévoit aussi de
faciliter certains projets d'immobilier
d'entreprise grâce à la création d'une
procédure administrative intégrée en
outre la mise en œuvre expérimentale
dans quelques régions d'un certificat de
projet était également très
encourageante en effet la sécurité
juridique et la stabilité des Normes
garanties par ce certificat au porteur
de projet pendant 18 mois qui suivent sa
délivrance démultipliera très rapidement
les initiatives trop souvent freiné par
la complexité mais aussi par
l'instabilité de tout un ensemble de
règles fiscales sociales et
environnementales les mesures visantes à
favoriser le financement participatif
des entreprises sont également les
bienvenus dans le contexte actuel quant
à l'article 2 qui porte sur le droit des
entreprises en difficulté il aurait sans
doute comme l'a souligné le rapporteur
mérité de faire l'objet d'un projet de
loi à part entière si cet article vise à
juste titre à renforcer l'efficacité des
procédures de prévention et à faciliter
la recherche de nouveaux financement il
il instaure également une nouvelle
procédure de liquidation judiciaire
ultra simplifiée qui pose quelques
difficultés le rapporteur soulligne dans
son rapport sa crainte je cite que c'est
nouvelle procédure soit une occasion de
fraude de la part de débiteurs
organisant leur insolvabilité ou
souhaitant soustraire des actifs à leur
créancier pour limiter ce risque il a
donc fait adopter l'amendement prévoyant
des mécanismes de contrôle ce qui est
bien il est permis de s'interroger sur
l'intérêt d'une procédure ultra
simplifiée qui nécessite la mise en uvre
de contrôles supplémentaires qui vont
forcément alourdir alors sommes nous
réellement donc dans la simplification
permettez-moi également de souligner que
ce projet de loi comprend un certain
nombre d'habilitations dans le lien avec
la simplification et la sécurisation de
la vie des entreprise est loin d'être
évident même si certaines d'entre elles
sont très importantes les introdues dans
le texte donnent un peu une impression
de manque de cohérence et peut susciter
une certaine confusion parmi ces
articles dont le lien avec l'intitulé du
projet de loi n'est pas flagrant figure
l'article 20 auquels les membres du RDS
sont très attachés et dont je souhaite
ici souligner l'importance l'adoption de
cette article même s'il ne se trouve
probablement pas dans le bon véhicule
législatif est absolument indispensable
sans quoi la caisse commune de sécurité
sociale de l'oser mise en place à titre
expérimental depuis 2009 cerait tout
simplement d'exister au 1er janvier
prochain actuellement seul à lososer
cher à notre collègue ami Alain Bertrand
a mis en place un guichet unique pour le
régime général de sécurité sociale la
branche de famille et le recourant des
cotisations cette expérimentation a fait
é preuv pour épendre besoin des
territoires ruraux ou ép ruraux et pour
éviter d'accroître la fracture
territoriale au détriment des
populations mon département le lotte
pourrait d'ailleurs à la lumière de
cette expérience envisager d'en
bénéficier pour finir permettez-moi
d'exprimer des regrets quant aux
conditions d'examen de ce texte soumis à
la procédure accélérée et de le nombre
d'articles a signif significativement
augmenté du fait de l'adoption
d'amendement du gouvernement à
l'Assemblée nationale et surtout lors de
l'examen du texte en commission
assurement la loi devient bavarde même
s'il s'agit d'habilitation à prendre des
mesures par ordonnance C articles n'en
nécessitent pas moins un contrôle
parlementaire rigoureux celui-ci est
rendu en partie impossible avec
l'adoption de mesures complémentaires
déposé à la dernière minute et que nous
devons examiner dans des conditions et
des délis insatisfaisants malgré ces
réserves et en espérant l'adoption de
notre amendement sur la signalytique du
tri des déchets le groupe RDSE soutient
endra ce projet de loi qui est attendu
par les entreprises je rappelle que la
Commission européenne estime qu'une
baisse de 25 % des charges des
entreprise représenterait une économie
de 15 milliards d'euros en France et
permettrait une augmentation de la
croissance de 08 points à court terme et
de 1.4 à long terme il faudit donc
poursuivre il faut donc poursuivre ces
efforts en ce sens pour terminer je
rappelle que la France et le pays
d'Europe où les prélèvements
obligatoires sur les entreprises sont
les plus élevés 26 et5 % de la valeur
ajoutée dès lors ce sont aussi ces
prélèvements et en particulier la char
sociale des entreprises qui faut alléger
les membres du RDSE espère que la grande
remise en place fiscale prévue dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finances pour
2015 en sera
l'occasion merci Monsieur Jean-Claude
requier la parole est à Monsieur Alain
Richard monsieur le président prident
madame la ministre me reviens au nom de
mon groupe de vous apporter un soutien
avec éventuellement quelques
observations et suggestion pour faire
progresser ce projet de loi qui a déjà
reçu la l'approbation de l'Assemblée
nationale la simplification est une
mission à laquelle je crois nous
adhérons
tous et qui demande de reprendre un bref
temps de
réflexion pour essayer de comprendre les
questions de société
sous-jacente quand on parle de
simplification on porte donc un une
appréciation alors économique social
sociétal pour dire nous avons
aujourd'hui un dispositif d'encadrement
juridique de des activités de la société
qui est excessif et qui est en partie
dysfonctionnel et il se produit un peu
trop souvent que ce soit dans le cadre
dans l'enceinte du Parlement même ou
dans les débats académiques qui
l'accompagnent que ceci soit traduit en
terme de bien et de mal de répartition
de la faute de la simplification enfin
de l'absence de simplification de la
surcharge juridique et réglementaire
alors qu'il me semble que notre mission
aujourd'hui devant les difficultés
sérieuses que connaissent c'est vrai un
certain nombre de fonctions sociales
dont la fonction d'entreprendre n'est
pas tant de distribuer des bons ou des
mauvais points mais d'essayer de de
revenir un peu sur les mouvements
d'intérêt en confrontation dans la
société qui ont conduit à cette addition
cet empilement normatif et essayer au
contraire de rechercher les intérêts
communs qui peuvent exister dans une
société complexe pour rétablir un un
système de règles opérationnel équitable
et durable donc je je fais appel très
modestement à ce que nous n'ayons pas
une approche moralisatrice ou ou
distributrice de critique sur ce sujet
mais que nous essayons et c'était encore
ce que nous faisions à l'initiative de
la Commission d'application application
des lois la semaine
dernière de comprendre les mécanismes
qui ont conduit à l'empilement et
d'essayer de les les traiter sur le
fond le présent texte est donc concentré
sur les alors après effectivement on
pourra faire l'observation qu'il y a
quelques éléments de dispersion mais
l'essentiel de des objectifs de de ce
présent projet de de loi est concentré
sur les charges normatives pesant sur
les entreprises et son principal mérite
et de proposer à travers ces vrais des
habilitations une série de modifications
concrètes qui sont en mesure de prendre
effet dès les premiers mois de 2014 et
ce que je vourrais souligner pour
équilibrer quelque peu les observations
euh tout à fait tout à fait légitime et
tout à fait justifiable qui regrette
l'absence de débat parlementaire
approfondi je crois que la ministre
pourra le repréciser à l'occasion de tel
ou tel des articles l'essentiel des
mesures de simplification dont on parle
font l'objet de concertation préalable
déjà approfondi et j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour relever le la grande
qualité des travaux de nos rapporteurs
la plus les rapports font état de
beaucoup de ces concertations qui
démontrent qu'il ne s'agit pas de
mesures de simplification qui ont été
inventées je dirais de façon improvisée
mais qui sont le résultat de de travaux
issus justement des différents intérêts
de la société et qui on le verra je
crois lorsque les ordonnances seront
publiées feront l'objet d'une
approbation générale des acteurs
concerné je voudrais ajouter face
notamment aux interrogations qui portent
sur le défaut d'urgence ou sur la
possibilité de poursuivre le débat sur
le plan parlementaire que certaines des
dispositions qui sont proposées et qui
peuvent donc donner lieu à la sortie à
l'approbation de texte de valeur
législative dans un délai assez court
sont aussi des opérations de
sécurisation
car une partie des modifications qui
vont intervenir par ordonnance si la
l'habilitation est approuvée vont
permettre de régler des situations de
fragilité juridique soit parce que nous
sommes en présence aujourd'hui de texte
contradictoir et donc de réelle
difficultés dans l'application de la loi
soit résulte de la survenue de décisions
juridictionnelles qui ont fragilisé le
droit existant qu'il s'agisse de la
juridiction judiciaire ou qu'il s'agisse
du Conseil constitutionnel
donc il me semble qu'il y a au moins des
des arguments sérieux pour justifier le
recours à l'habilitation qui comme c'est
naturel développe des interrogations et
c'est vrai ont développé à développé
dans le passé sous la précédente
majorité des interrogations de même
nature il me semble que suivant et et
Monsieur Richard le disait d'ailleurs
très justement suivant le type de
disposition qui est envisagé et suivant
leur degré de maturation en terme
d'apport juridique on peut me
semble-t-il avoir un jugement nuancé et
reconnaître l'utilité de cette de cette
procédure que d'ailleurs depuis 55 ans
qu'elle figure dans la Constitution
personne n'a jamais
modifié par par la simple mention de
quelques-unes des mesures qui sont
prévues et que pour ma part j'approuve
pleinement avec quelques années
d'expérience de contact de législateur
avec les entre ise et notamment avec les
petites et moyennes entreprises je sais
que ces mesures apporteront
effectivement des progrès concrets je
pense à à la réduction des obligations
de publication de comptes pour les
micro-entreprises je pense à au
développement enfin l'encouragement en
tout cas de la facturation électronique
pour les entreprises fournisseurs de
marchés publics je pense ça c'est un
aussi c'est un un programme si vous
voulez qui s'est développé et qui a
connu une approbation importante dans la
société le développement du financement
participatif il y a un ensemble d'autres
mesures de simplification dans le
domaine du droit des affaires qui c'est
vrai en pure théorie serait parfaitement
euh intéressante à débattre devant le
Parlement enfin avec un peu d'expérience
nous savons aussi que ce serait un débat
de de spécialistes
auquel quelques-uns seulement d'entre
nous prendrions part et si c'est un
point sur lequel je reviendrai le
gouvernement se montre vraiment
déterminé à poursuivre la concertation
avec la les parlementaire pendant la
période d'habilitation je crois que nous
ne serons pas loin d'avoir la même
qualité de débat que si on était passé
effectivement dans les émicycle je vrais
appeler l'attention des collègues sur
trois ou quatre sujets qui me paraissent
particulièrement positif même s'ils
peuvent donner lieu à discussion je
pense en particulier à l' adaptation de
nos textes du Code monétaire et
financier au droit de l'Union européenne
pour la surveillance prunentielle des
établissement
financier il
serait singulier alors que la France a
mener le débat au sein de l'Union
européenne depuis des mois pour obtenir
des décisions de principe importantes
qui habilite la la Banque centrale
européenne à monter un système efficace
de
d'encadrement prudentiel des
établissements financiers que nous
soyons parmi les derniers ensuite à
transposer ces dispositions ces
dispositions je crois font l'objet d'un
accord très large en tout cas c'est ce
que nous avons vérifié à la commission
des affaires européennes lorsque nous en
avons parlé il y a vraiment une un
succès de la France en terme et c'est
autant plus vrai que il y avait pas
convergence au départ entre la France et
l'Allemagne sur ce sujet donc la France
a je crois fait sérieusement avancer la
la réflexion européenne en matière
d'encadrement et de sécurisation du
système bancaire je crois que nous nous
pouvons habiliter le gouvernement à
aller vite pour mettre pour transposer
ces nouvelles dispositions dans notre
droit
financier je je voudrais aussi souligner
que la réforme d'ailleurs limitée qui
est prévue des procédures collectives
dans une période de ralentissement
économique où nous voyons
adéiablement un certain nombre
d'entreprises un nombre croissant
d'entreprises aller devant les tribun
notre commerce c'est un ensemble de
dispositions et et je rejoins d'ailleurs
la la la précision dans l'habilitation
qui a été suggérée par
notre par notre rapporteur tan Mohamed
soilili mais je crois que cette
modification limité d'un sujet dont on
dont on discute depuis des années sur
lequel les positions des uns et des
autres sont bien connues et qui aura un
effet d'amélioration du sauvetage de ce
qui peut l'être dans les entreprises en
difficulté je crois que nous nous jouons
notre rôle en permettant au gouvernement
de le faire par habilitation plutôt que
de reporter une nouvelle fois la
réalisation de de cette réforme je
reviens que brièvement puisque des
collègues ont dit tout à fait ce que ce
que nous pensons au groupe socialiste
sur les deux procédures spécifiques
introduites en matière de droit de
l'environnement dont je veux préciser
d'ailleurs je veux remercier notre
collègue Esther ben Bassa qui s'est
exprimé au nom du groupe écologiste pour
la bonne fois avec laquelle elle a
abordé le sujet je veux préciser que ces
deux procédures simplifi qui est en
matière de droit de l'environnement ne
réduisent aucune des conditions de fond
c'est-à-dire que les obligations de
respect de l'environnement du paysage du
voisinage et cetera qui s'applique par
exemple à l'implantation de d'éolienne
reste en vigueur et que c'est simplement
la procédure de vérification que ces
conditions sont remplies qui va être
simplifié il en va de même pour le
certificat de projet alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a quelques cas spécifiques qui
qui pent à interrogation parce que ce
sont disons des
jonction on va dire sobrement au au cœur
du projet alors c'est vrai de la la
réforme qui affecte les relations entre
le syndicat des transports
d'Île-de-France et la Société du Grand
Paris mais sauf erreur de ma part ce
texte rencontre l'accord de tous les
partenaires du système de transport
parisien et d'autre part permet une
réalisation plus plus fluide plus
efficace d'un projet majeur et
d'ailleurs de de très fort niveau
financier puisqu'on est aux environ 30
milliards d'euros qui est un des
éléments les plus importants de
rebondissement économique de
l'île-de-fance de la région capitale
donc ça n'est quand même pas tout à fait
sans lien avec le l'objet du du projet
c'est vrai qu'il y a des dispositions
sur les professions réglementées
notamment sur les avocats au Conseil et
sur les notaires mais nous ne pouvons
pas à longueur d'année nous plaindre de
la rigidité de ces profession et
notamment de la présence de leur numérus
clausus et ne pas approuver une
disposition qui a quand même pour effet
tout ça simple sur le plan économique et
ça pourra se voir dans les tarifs
euh de réduction de numérus clausus qui
ont eu un effet indéiablement maltusien
jusqu'à présent dans le fonctionnement
de ces ces professions j'ajoute un autre
texte donc je crois qu'il il est
cohérent avec l'objectif de de faciliter
la vie des entreprises il arrive c'est
vrai sous forme d'amendement au Sénat
parce que ça a été une question de
calendrier je crois que nous sommes tous
favorables à la réforme du régime
d'assurance vie qui conduit les comptes
les contrats d'assurance vie à apporter
un financement substantiel au
financement des une contribution
substantiel au financement des PME la
partie fiscale de ce texte va figurer
dans la loi de finance rectificative
comme c'est logique la partie de droit
des assurances doit bien avoir un
support si on veut que cette disposition
importante pour le financement des PME
soit applicable en 2014 évidemment le
texte que nous présente Madame la
Ministre est opportun pour pour réaliser
cette réforme
je je termine en soulignant d'une part
que j'y insiste tous ces projets ont été
concertés et ne sont ne seront des
surprises pour aucun des
partenaires que si on veut comme l'a
fait tout à fait légitimement monsieur
richchard analyser si le gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui joue le jeu de
l'habilitation nous avons déjà qu même
deux dossiers sur la table nous avons
habilité le gouvernement et
spécifiquement euh la ministre du
Logement a adopté des dispositions
tendantes à par par ordonnance à
faciliter la construction de logement
tout le monde a pu observer ce qu'il y
avait dans l'ordonnance en question qui
a été rendu en peu de mois elle a
répondu très exactement et sans aucune
critique à l'habilitation qui avait été
donnée quant à l'habilitation pour
réaliser une série de mesures de
simplification des relations entre
l'administration et les citoyens je veux
vous dire que siégeant en votre nom à la
Commission de quodification nous
examinerons vendredi le premier projet
du code de des relations entre
l'administration et les citoyens donc
cette habilitation est bien aussi en
train en train d'être appliqué
loyalement et
fidèlement alors il reste madame la
ministre à ce que vous vous
leviez dans le cours de notre débat tout
doute sur la
volonté déterminé du gouvernement à
jouer le jeu de l'Association des
parlements à l'approbation à la
préparation de ces ordonnances c'est
vrai que ça a été à plus d'une reprise
un élément de langage émis par le
gouvernement au cours des débats
parlementaires dont la traduction
effective a parfois laissé quelquesuns
d'entre nous un peu
perplexe donc comme il y a à la fin un
rendez-vous à la fois légal et politique
et celui de la
ratification je pense que le
gouvernement se simplifierait la vie en
démontrant de façon tout à fait franche
et tout à fait pratique sa volonté de
faire participer les parlementaires
spécialisés sur chacun des domaines ils
sont tous connus ils sont tous
identifiés à la préparation des
ordonnances dont nous parlons et je suis
sûr que si si le gouvernement agit ainsi
et je lui fais confiance pour répondre à
cette demande et bien la ratification
des ordonnances en question puisque de
toute façon elles auront lieu sera
quelque chose de beaucoup plus simple et
de beaucoup plus confiant je crois que
c'est un contrat de confiance que le
gouvernement peut nous offrir et qui
nous aidera à soutenir ce projet
d'habilitation qui je crois a de bons
motifs merci Monsieur Alain
Richard madame Laurence Rossignol
rapporteur pour avis de la commission du
développement
durable
monsieur le Président
bonjour monsieur le Président Madame la
ministres messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues d'abord pardonnez-moi de
d'avoir pris un peu de liberté par
rapport à notre déroul habituel qui veut
que normalement les rapports pour avis a
lieu avant la discussion générale et je
vous remercie de votre indulgence la
commission du développement durable
s'est saisi pour avis du projet de loi
habilitant le gouvernement à simplifier
et à sécuriser le droit des entreprise
l'objectif de ce texte a été dit par les
précédents rapporteurs par plusieurs
orateurs d'ction générale est d'alléger
les charges administratif pesant sur les
entreprises afin de renforcer leur
compétitivité et de faciliter la vie de
nos entrepreneurs plusieurs dispositions
concernent directement la modernisation
du droit de l'environnement et des
procédures d'autorisation
environnementale nous nous sommes donc
saisis deux sujets complémentaires
intéressent notre commission le Grand
Paris et la sign aléthique imposé sur
les produits recyclables d'abord une
petite remarque sur la méthode avant
d'entrer dans l'analyse du dispositif le
gouvernement a choisi de recourir aux
ordonnances de l'article 38 de la
Constitution il s'agit et ça a déjà été
évoqué en pratique de gagner plusieurs
mois ce n'est pas anecdotique au regard
de l'objectif du texte qui est de
simplifier sans tarder notre droit sans
pour autant en ce qui nous concerne
commission Développement Durable
sacrifier les exigences
environnementales au-delà de la méthode
peu criticable en l'espèce l'enjeu
réside dans l'amélioration du suivi de
l'habilitation par le Parlement c'est
pourquoi je me félicite que le
gouvernement comme il s'y était engagé
et comme il l'avait d'ailleurs déjà fait
pour le projet de loi laabilitant à
légiférer par ordonnance sur la
participation du public aux décisions
ayant une incidence environnementale
comme donc le gouvernement s'est engagé
de nouveau dans ce texte il a
effectivement transmis à notre
commission en fin de semaine semaine
dernière les projets d'ordonnan relatifs
aux articles 13 14 et additionnels après
l'article 14 c'est une bonne pratique et
à tous nos collègues qui s'inquiètent de
la place du Parlement dans une procédure
d'habilitation à légiférer par
ordonnance j'indique que ces ordonnances
les projets d'ordonnance et leur
transmission au Parlement sont de nature
normalement à satisfaire une grande
partie de leurs inquiétudes notre
Commission a reçu de la commission des
lois une délégation au fond pour
l'examen des articles des articles 8 sur
le Grand Paris et 16 sur la signale
éthique des produits recyclables nous
nous sommes par ailleurs saisi pour avis
des articles 9 sur les obligations de
reporting social et environnemental des
mutuels et 13 et 14 relative à
l'expérimentation d'un permis
environnemental unique pour les
entreprises je commencerai donc par la
présentation des articles qui nous ont
été délégués au fond l'article 8
autorise le gouvernement à prendre par
voie d'ordonnance plusieurs mesures
relatives au Grand Paris qui
apparaissent comme la conséquence
logique du discours du premier ministre
du 6 mars dernier cet article vise à
autoriser la Société du Grand Paris à
financer ou à exercer la maîtrise
d'ouvrage de projets d'infrastructure
destiné à offrir des correspondances
avec le réseau de transport public du
Grand Paris il estant au Syndicat des
transports d'île-de-fance au STIF la
possibilité de lui confier toute mission
d'intérêt générale en lien avec ses
compétences l'article habilite enfin le
gouvernement à dé terminer la procédure
de modification du schéma d'ensemble du
réseau de transport public du Grand
Paris notre commission a estimer que la
détermination de la procédure de
révision du schéma d'ensemble
consistuait constituait un enjeu tel que
le Parlement ne pouvait être dcaisi de
son élaboration ma commission notre
commission n'a donc pas adopté l'article
8 ce que je regrette car il s'agissait
simplement de combler un vide juridique
la loi relative au Grand Paris ne
prévoit pas de procédure de révision du
schéma or il est apparu en début d'année
que des ajustements pouvaient s'avérer
nécessaires le Conseil d'État en avait
d'ailleurs recommandé une procédure
claire de révision l'article 16 sur
lequel notre commission était également
saisie au fond et qui n'est pas un
article d'habilitation mais qui est un
article
de de travail législatif d'élaboration
et de de vote direct de la loi l'article
16 vise à reporter du 1er janvier 2012
au 1er janvier 2015 l' obligation de
mettre en place une signalétique commune
le fameux logo triman sur les produits
recyclables soumis à un dispositif de
tri il n'ura échapper à personne que le
1er janvier 2012 est déjà derrière nous
et que donc cet article vise à donner un
peu de délai supplémentaire pour
l'adoption d'un pour pour l'élaboration
par le gouvernement d'un décret qui
aurait déjà dû être pris depuis près de
ans l'objectif de cette disposition qui
était donc prévu dans lo gronel 2 est
d'harmoniser les marques de recyclage
mis sur les prod sur le marché et sur
les produits qui sur lesquels ils sont
inscrits afin de simplifier le geste de
tri les quantités de produits recyclés
doivent être doivent en être accru pour
un plus grand bénéfice environnemental
et les erreurs de tri pour un plus grand
bénéfice économique des
collectivités notre commission a adopté
trois amendements absolument identique
et qui qui aboutissent tous purement et
simplement à à à a supprimé le
dispositif tri tel qu'il était organisé
dans la loi Grenel 2 cette solution m'a
semblé un peu radicale la suppression
totale de la loi d'une partie de la loi
Grenel 2 et je crains que d'autres
parlementaires en aent été un peu
frustré puisque de nombreux amendements
avaient été déposés pour aménager ce
fameux article et que nous n'avons
malheureusement pas pu les examiner
puisqu'ils sont tous tombés par
l'adoption des articles les plus
radicaux des amendements les plus R
radicaux c'est pour cette raison que
j'ai choisi de cigner de vous proposer
en de cossigner un amendement
rétablissant le dispositif tout en
prévoyant cependant une exemption pour
le verre on peut en effet estimer que la
recyclabilité du ver est bien connu des
citoyens et le recyclage des bouteilles
et aut autrep et beaucau de confiture
s'il peut toujours être amélioré est
déjà aujourd'hui plutôt élevé et que
le usager devant ses poubelles à parfois
quelques interrogations il prend son
produit regarde le produit regarde
l'emballage il cherche sur le produit
sur l'emballage une indication il ne la
trouve pas puisqu'il n'y a pas à l'heure
actuelle d'harmonisation de la
Signaléthique donc il est perplexe et il
va choisir une ou l'autre des poubelles
et il se trompe quand même au point que
on puisse évaluer à 241 millions d'euros
par an le coût pour les collectivités
territoriales des erreurs de tri mais
néanmoins il y a un produit sur lequel
il ne se trompe pas c'est le verre tout
le monde sait où sont les poubelles
vertes il m'a donc semblé utile de
rétablir de vous proposer de rétablir le
dispositif triman en en excluant le vert
j'en arrive aux articles dont notre
commission s'était saisie pour avis
l'article 9 qui vise à assouplir les
obligations des mutuelles et des
établissements de crédit en matière de
reporting social et environnemental
depuis la loi de 2001 relative aux
nouvelles régulations économiques le
code de commerce prévoit que les
sociétés cotées doivent inclure des
informations sur la manière dont elles
prennent en compte les conséquences
sociales et environnementales de leur
activité dans leur rapport annuel la loi
Grenel 2 a étendu en 2010 cette
obligation aux sociétés non côté aux
coopératives aux sociétés d'assurance
ainsi qu'au mutuel dont le dont le total
de bilan ou le chiffre d'affaires et le
nombre de salariés excède certains seuil
initialement donc seul les mutuels
dépassant ce seuil était tenu d'inclure
des informations à caractère social et
environnemental dans leur rapport de
gestion cependant la loi de régulation
bancaire de 2010 a supprimé
manifestement par erreur un législateur
a peut-être eu un moment de radicalisme
peut-être aussi voilà parfois ça arrive
ou de de d'insouciance et il a supprimé
par erreur le renvoi aux conditions de
seuil en état de droit les mutuels
etétablissements de crédit sont donc
soumis à des obligations plus strictes
que les sociétés non côtées ce qui
paraît tout à fait anormal l'article 9
rétablit donc le dispositif initial en
introduisant de nouveau la référence au
seuil pour l'application de l'obligation
de reporting social et environnemental
mutuel conformément au droit commun
notre commission a émis un avis
favorable à l'adoption de cet article
les articles 13 et 14 visent à mettre en
place à titre expérimental et dans
certaines régions des procédures
simplifiées innovantes il s'agit de
faciliter la réalisation de projets
d'activités économique sans pour autant
diminuer les exigences environnementales
les deux dispositifs en envisagé découle
de proposition formulées lors des états
généraux de la modernisation du droit de
l'environnement à terme l'objectif est
de définir un permis environnemental
unique afin de mieux articuler les
procédures entre autorisation
environnementale et autorisation
d'urbanisme et donc de simplifier les
démarches administratives pour les
porteurs de projets l'article 13 prévoit
la délivrance au porteurs d'un projet
d'activité économique soumis à certaines
autorisations administratives régies par
les dispositions du code de
l'environnement du code forestier ou du
Code de l'Urbanisme d'un document appelé
certificat de projet ce document devrait
comporter un engagement de l'État sur la
liste des autorisations nécessaires pour
réaliser le projet notamment les
autorisations relevant du code de
l'environnement du code forestier ou du
Code de l'Urbanisme le certificat
mentionnera également si le projet doit
être soumis à une étude d'impact et si
c'est le cas le degré de précision des
informations à fournir dans l'étude
d'impact le certificat pourrait enfin
valoir engagement de l'administration
sur le délai d'instruction des
autorisations sollicitées afin de
garantir au porteurs de projet un
traitement dans un dél raisonnable dans
au moins une des régions retenues pour
l'expérimentation le certificat de
projet pourra valoir certificat
d'urbanisme il pourra également
comporter une garantie du maintien en
vigueur pendant une durée déterminée des
dispositions législatives et
réglementaires relatives aux
autorisations sollicitées de cette
manière les entreprises concernées
pourront bénéficier d'une forme de
cristallisation ou de sanctuirisation de
la réglementation la rédaction initiale
de l'article ne mentionnait pas les
conditions dans lesquelles le recours
contre ces certificats de projet pouvait
être déposé un amendement du
Gouvernement adopté en commission des
lois a permis de combler cette lacune en
effet il ne faudrait pas créer sous
couvert de simplification un nouveau
type de décision entraînant la
multiplication des contentieux donc
l'amendement du Gouvernement sur les
recours vise non pas à faciliter les
contentieux et alourdir les procédures
mais au contraire en en déterminer les
conditions de façon à maîtriser les
contentieux notre commission a émis un
avis FA favorable à à l'adoption de
l'article 13 ainsi complété l'article 14
prévoit une expérimentation similaire
mais cette fois pour les installation
classé pour la protection de
l'environnement dit ICPE soumise à
autorisation aujourd'hui les porteurs de
projets relatifs à une ICPE doivent
parfois déposer jusqu'à cinq demandes
d'autorisation ou de dérogation
différentes une autorisation en
application de la réglementation des
installation classé pour la protection
de l'environnement une demande de
dérogation au titre des règles relatives
à la faune et à la fur protégée une
demande de permis de construire au titre
de l'urbanisme une autorisation de
défrichement en application du Code
forestier une autorisation d'exploiter
au titre du code de l'énergie vous me
concéderez mes chers collègues que il
faut une grande énergie pour euh suivre
l'ensemble de ces procédures ces
procédures qui sont instruites par des
services de l'État différents
aboutissent plus fréquemment que ça ne
le devrait à des décisions divergentes
des des différents services de l'État
l'article 14 prévoit donc d'expérimenter
pour des installations de production
d'énergie renouvelable en particulier la
mise mise en placeun procédure unique
construite autour d'une procédure
d'autorisation relative aux ICPE qui
intégrera toutes les autorisations
requises au titre des législation que je
vous ai cité l'objectif est d'accélérer
et de rationaliser des procédures
multiples longues et parfois redondantes
notre commission a la encore émis un
avis favorable il faudra sans doute
compléter l'expérimentation de cette
procédure nouvelle par une réflexion sur
le délai de caducité des autorisations
ICPE aujourd'hui pour une autorisation
d'installation éolienne le délai de
raccordement au réseau peut prendre
jusqu'à 8 ans alors même que
l'autorisation devient Cadu au bout de 3
ans si des travaux significatifs n'ont
pas été entrepris ce frein juridique
retarde le développement de la filière
et si les lois d'habilitation c'est si
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel n'était pas aussi
stricte sur notre capacité d'amendement
en matière de loi d'habilitation
j'aurais volontiers introduit un
amendement visant à lever euh les
obstacles de la caducité lorsque la
caducité n'est pas du fait du porteur de
projet voilà dans l'ensemble ces mesures
de simplification vont dans le bon sens
pour autant il reste encore beaucoup à
faire pour moderniser le droit de
l'environnement la feuille de route
issue des États généraux comportait
trois parties mieux choisir élaborer les
règles de droit de l'environnement
accélérer et faciliter la réalisation
des projets respectueux de
l'environnement et enfin mieux réparer
et sanctionner les atteintes à
l'environnement le deuxème volet relatif
à l'accélération des projets est
largement mis en œuvre par les articles
13 et 14 du projet de loi ainsi que par
les articles additionnels intégrés par
l'adoption des amendements du
Gouvernement il reste en revanche à
procéder et c'est urgent au niveau
national à une évaluation du droit
existant et de son impact une réflexion
devrait être engagée sur les règles
droit communautaires afin d'identifier
les textes européens qui nécessiteraient
également une simplification je vois que
notre collègue alin Richard monsieur
avec attention car il va au sein du
Conseil national de la transition
écologique être
chargé être chargé de cette mission de
la suite de la poursuite des états
généraux de droit de l'environnement et
il aura à ses côtés comme allié la
commission du développement durable je
lu jeen témoigne et enfin la création
d'un groupe de travail est également
prévue pour formuler des propositions
visant à établir un meilleur équilibre
entre accès au juges et sécurité
juridique des procédures il pourrait
s'agir de donner la possibilité de
saisir le juge à un stade précoce afin
qu'il statue sur la régularité d'une
procédure et puisse prescrire les
mesures propres à reméer aux
irrégularités à ce titre l'avis du
Conseil d'État sur le rescrit sera très
intéressant enfin des groupes de travail
sont en train de se mettre en place au
sein du Conseil national comme je
l'évoquais il y a un instant pour
poursuivre le modernisation du droit de
l'environnement et le renforcement de la
protection de la biodiversité la
modernisation des enquêtes publiques à
la lecture de cette feuille de route
ambitieuse mais indispensable au regard
des difficultés constatées en pratique
par les élus locaux on constate qu'il y
a encore beaucoup à faire notre
commission du développement durable il
sera très attentive et très active je
vous remercie chers collègues madame la
ministre de votre attention
merci Madame Laurence
Rossignol madame la
ministreésent Mesdames et Messieurs les
les sénateurs je crois que cette
discussion générale a montré une chose
c'est que nous convergeons tous sur tous
les bancs sur l'objectif que poursuit le
gouvernement c'est-à-dire simplifier la
vie des entreprises en tant que ministre
des PME je je précise que au cours des
dernières années 80 % de la création
d'emploi se fait dans les petites et
moyennes entreprises et ce projet de loi
ilitation il vise bien à faciliter la
vie de ces acteurs économiques qui sont
ceux sur lequels nous nous appuyons nous
devons nous appuyer pour consolider la
reprise économique qui s'annonce je
crois que c'est un objectif sur lequel
nous pouvons tous nous accorder alors
pour répondre plus précisément au
rapporteur so soili je vous remercie
d'avoir rappelé l'enjeu de compétitivité
que ce projet de que porte ce projet de
loi et l'accord dont il pourrait faire
l'objet ainsi que je viens de le dire
au-delà des des clivages partisans merci
également d'avoir rappelé la cohérence
du texte qui est centré sur la la vie
des entreprises la vie quotidienne des
entreprises d'avoir cité aussi les
chiffres euh qui qui montrent bien les
économies qui pourraent être réalisés
par les entreprises et puis en terme de
temps aussi et et et de et de valeur
merci enfin du dialogue constructif que
nous avons pu mener plusieurs d'entre
vous l'ont souligné dans la précision du
champ des habilitations des ajustements
mineurs vont être proposés par
amendement vous sont proposé par
amendement mais je crois que nous avons
parcouru ensemble l'ensemble l'essentiel
du du chemin j'entends aussi votre
souhait d'être plus particulièrement
associé aux ordonnances de l'article 2
et et je m'engage j'aurai l'occasion de
le faire aussi sur d'autres sujets mais
je m'engage vraiment personnellement à
ce que les ordonnances vous soient
présentées dès qu'il dès qu'il sera
possible et afin de faciliter le travail
conjoint le travail coopératif
collaboratif que nous souhaitons mener
avec le Parlement sur sur ces
ordonnances j'entends également monsieur
le rapporteur votre volonté par un
amendement à l'article 10 de préciser
que la modernisation de l'État
actionnaire ne doit pas se faire faire
au détriment de la représentation des
salariés je souscris parfaitement à cet
objectif et le gouvernement vous
proposera un ajustement rédactionnel qui
permettra précisément de consolider la
mise en œuvre de cette de cet
amendement pour répondre au rapporteur
pour avis monsieur vugrenard vous avez
rappeler l'importance d'une démarche
partenariale entre les administrations
de terrain et les entreprises tel est
bien l'esprit de de ce projet de loi
dont j'ai dit qu'il participait d'une
évolution culturelle de l'administration
je crois que c'est important de de le
souligner vous avez également rappelé à
juste titre l'intérêt budgétaire des
mesures envisagées qui permettront des
économies considérables par la
dématérialisation à la fois pour les
entreprises mais aussi pour les
administrations publiques nous entendons
votre volonté de d'introduire de la
progressivité dans la mise en œuvre ce
sera évidemment le cas pour le passage à
la facturation électronique afin que
tout le monde puisse bien se préparer à
cette à cette évolution je souscris
également à votre proposition d'associer
les parlementaires aux ordonnances que
que cela soit par une consultation
particulière en cas de
consultation publique ou par une
consultation spécifique des commissions
concernées en l'absence de consultation
publique sur l'article 10 je vous
renouvelle les remerciements adressés à
Monsieur soalili la rédaction à laquelle
vous êtes parvenu convient sous réserve
d'ajustement extrêmement mineur au
projet du gouvernement et puis l'idée
que vous avez évoqué d'un test Kafka le
nom est très évocateur dans les études
d'impact est une piste intéressante et
je dois vous dire qu'elle est
actuellement à l'étude puisque parmi les
mesures qui sont examinées pour
faciliter la vie des entreprises
simplifier la vie des entreprises et
notamment des plus petites d'entre elles
il y avait cette idée de test PME qui
vise précisément à évaluer l'impact sur
le fonctionnement quotidien des PME de
toute nouvell réglementation alors c'est
une démarche qui est un petit peu lourde
bien évidemment pour les pour les
services pour les administrations mais
c'est une une expérimentation que nous
sommes actuellement mes services en
train de avec mes services en train de
de mener sur un certain nombre de
réglementations afin de pouvoir étudier
sa
généralisation monsieur le rapporteur
pour avis François patria vous avez Avaz
rappelé combien le choc de
simplification dépasse le périmètre du
du travail législatif je dois souligner
à quel point ce travail législatif est
néant moins moteur et à quel point il ne
peut y avoir de simplification sans
l'appui et le support et le soutien du
Parlement vous avez insisté sur les
article qui favorise et sécurise le
financement des entreprises c'est
effectivement extrêmement important dans
la situation macro-économique actuelle
il s'agit de dispositions majeures sans
lesquelles les nouvelles possibilités
données aux entreprises risquent de les
rester lettre morte donc évidemment
les questions liées à la réforme de
l'assurance vie ou encore au financement
participatif à laquelle vous avez bien
raison je suis tout particulièrement
attaché qui pourrait donner aussi un
signau de modernité également à
l'international euh dans dans dans le
cadre de de de cette réforme madame la
sénatrice ben Bassa euh la volonté du
gouvernement euh dans dans dans le cadre
de de ce projet de loi d'habilitation
est effectivement de de frapper vite
enfin frapper dans le bon sens du terme
frapper vite et fort au bénéfice des des
entreprises et c'est ce qui explique les
délais d'habilitation qui je je j'en
conviens sont sont brefs mais aussi le
le recours à la procédure accélérée je
crois que je l'ai rappelé en préambule
tout le monde euh reconnaît l'urgence
qu'il y a aujourd'hui à prendre des
mesures qui visent à soutenir nos
entreprises dans dans le cadre dans
l'investissement dans la création de
d'activités dans la création d'emploi et
je crois qu'il est nécessaire de de
considérer cela comme comme une urgence
s'agissant des expérimentations de
procédures intégrées en en matière
environnementale des délais plus courts
seront infecteur d'incitation au projet
éolien et de de méthanisation cette
réduction de délis qui est obtenue en
menant plusieurs procédures de front
Nura et il faut le souligner toutefois
nullement pour effet de réduire
l'exigence qualitative en matière
environnementale donc il est bien
important de souligner que c'est une
mesure de simplification qui ne vise pas
à réduire nos exigences en matière
environnementale euh monsieur le
sénateur rchard je constate que vous
partagez notre objectif de de de
simplification je soulligne que le
recours comme comm comme l'a rappelé
aussi le sénateur vugrenard le le
recours modeste qu'a fait le
gouvernement aux ordonnances dont je
rappelle qu'il n'y en a eu plus de 300
sous la précédente législature le
recours aux ordonnances est rendu
nécessaire ici encore une fois en raison
de l'urgence qui s'attache à donner de
l'air à nos entreprises et c'est
notamment le cas en matière d'obligation
comptbl et administrative l'urgence
sattache également à des dispositions
qui permettre la transposition de
directives qui doivent être mis en œuvre
en tout état de cause au 1er janvier
2014 c'est le cas de la directive crd4
qui met en œuvre les règles
prudentielles de de balle 3 sur le
certificat de projet je rappelle qu'il
ne s'agit pas de supprimer des
procédures mais de les traiter
simultanément ains que je viens de
l'indiquer c'est une mesure de sécurité
et non d'insécurité juridique il en est
de même sur les autorisations
d'éoliennne et les autres ICPE quant au
taux d'intérêt légal notre feuille de
route pour pour le réformer est clair il
est notamment proposé de l'améliorer en
différenciant les catégories de de
personnes professionnelles particulier
ou état vous dénoncez de manière plus
générale un patchwork de mesure mais vos
collègues au groupe UMP se sont
offusqués que ce projet de loi
d'habilitation n'aille pas plus loin
dans de plus nombreux domaines donc le
projet qui vous a présenté je crois
esttre équilibré il est proportionné à
l'urgence du choc de simplification et
vous vous plaignez vous-même de
dispositions de l'insuffisance de des
dispositions en matière de droit du
travail donc je crois que nous avons en
espèce un texte qui qui présente les
mesures nécesses et est proportionné
puis je vous rappelle que toutes les
mesures qui sont proposées ici l'ont été
à la demande des entreprises la demande
expresse euh et qui ont et les
dispositions qui en ont été écartées
l'ont été là aussi à la demande des
entreprises qui considéraient qu'elles
n'était pas forcément nécessaire ou ou
qu'elle n'avaiit pas forcément leur
place dans dans ce texte donc c'est le
cas de la simplification du bulletin de
paye par exemple pour vous donner une
illustration qui n'a de sens bien
entendu que si on simplifie les régimes
fiscaux et sociaux qui sendent ce ce
document de la de la même façon pour le
code du travail oui c'est vrai le code
du travail est un document épais trop
épais trop important en en poids ou en
volume mais le diviser par de n'aurait
de sens que si son contenu était rendu
plus plus maniable plus compréhensible
et donc il faut bien avoir une démarche
de simplification du contenu du texte
avant de proposer de la simplification
de des des processus ou des ou des
démarche pour répondre à Monsieur le
Sénateur de montescu je vous remercie de
votre adhésion à l'objectif du texte là
encore mais je relève qu'il ne
saurait-ce comparé à la loi varsman dont
je rappelle qu'elle elle comportait 134
articles dont beaucoup sont d'ailleurs
restés ltre morte et nous nous sommes
astreints dans le cas présent à la
cohérence vous dénoncez vous aussi un
ensemble hétérogène mais il est vrai
qu'il n'est pas facile de simplifier de
manière monolithique lorsque notamment
des simplifications s'imposent dans de
nombreux domaines vous vous en
conviendrez le gouvernement entend votre
volonté de rectifier l'article 16 pour
exclure le verre du dispositif sur le
contenu desabilités tion j'insiste sur
le travail important mené en commission
et qui qui a permis de préciser le champ
de des
habilitations pour répondre à madame la
sénatrice assassie sur la la
transposition des
directives prévu par l'article 12 c'est
l'urgence liée au délis de transposition
qui impose le recours à l'article 38 la
justice consulaire quant à elle sera
réformée dans un texte distinct qui sera
porté par la Chancellerie et puis sur le
délai de prévenance l'objectif est et je
crois qu'il est de le préciser de tirer
les conséquences du rapport de la Cour
de cassation qui préconisait une
meilleure articulation avec la fin de la
période d'cès et l'inscription au droit
positif de l'indemnisation des salariés
en cas de délais trop court sur
l'article 10 je donnerai un avis
favorable sous réserve d'un ajustement
rédactionnel à la précision demandée sur
la représentation des salariés je tiens
là aussi à préciser qu'il n'est pas
question de brader la part les
participations de l'État aucun niveau de
participation ne sera réduit et
l'objectif et d'assurer justement une
meilleure représentation de l'État dans
les entreprises dans lesquelles l'état
dispose d'une d'une participation euh à
la aux questions de de à l'intervention
de monsieur le sénateur reéquier je vous
remercie d'insister d'abord sur la
démarche dites-le nous une seule fois
qui résume bien l'esprit du texte faire
de l'administration à partenaire de
confiance des entreprises et jamais un
adversaire ou un ennemi nous savons que
le temps des entreprises est précieux
qui signifie souvent de l'argent
d'ailleurs je vous remercie d'insister
sur le nombre d'entreprises qui
bénéficieront des mesures du texte c'est
près d'un million pour les obligations
comptables simplifiées et 1 million de
petites entreprises les TPE et les PME
je vous confirme aussi l'entrée en
vigueur de la facturation électronique
qui vise notamment à réduire les délais
de paiement de manière progressive afin
que tout le monde puisse s s'y adapt et
s'y ajuster donc supportable une
démarche qui sera supportable pour pour
les PME ainsi que je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure quand au lien entre certaines
dispositions et la simplification vous
avez rappelé l'importance de la
sécurisation que porortte certaines
mesur comme la pérenisation de la caisse
de sécurité sociale de l'oser je
rappelle enfin que la simplification
permettra des économies qui seront
autant d'impôts en moins pour pour les
entreprises et pour et pour l'ensemble
des
contribuables monsieur le sénateur
Richard merci d'avoir remis ce texte à
sa juste place il SAG il s'agit bien
d'un texte d'intérêt général pris à la
demande des entreprises et qui devrait
être fédérateur merci également d'avoir
rappelé les raisons qui conduisent le
gouvernement à passer par l'article 38
et son engagement à mener une réelle
concertation sur les ordonnances et je
vous réitère l'engagement que j'ai pris
tout à l'heure à la tribune sur la
réalité la sincérité et et la profondeur
de cette de cette consultation et de
cette concertation merci enfin d'avoir
rappelé l'ancienneté des travaux du
Parlement sur les procédures collectives
qui ont d'ailleurs permis de mûir
longtemps cette cette réforme et puis
enfin sur les professions réglementées
je vous remercie d'avoir rappelé
l'importance de l'ouverture de ces
professions qui en l'occurrence est une
ouverture souhaitée par ces professions
l' l'ition nous dit que ce n'est pas
l'urgence mais je crois qu'il il y a
toujours urgence pour bien pour bien
faire et puis madame madame la sénatrice
Rossignol sur le Grand Paris je
comprends votre inquiétude relative à la
procédure de révision du schéma mais je
vous assure que le le gouvernement ne
porte aucun projet de modification du
schéma global dans l'immédiat il
s'agissait seulement de répondre à une
préoccupation du Conseil d'État de ne
pas voir cette procédure prévue dans le
dans le cadre du texte le gouvernement
est toutefois prêt à un rétablissement
de l'article sans sans le 3è alinéa et
puis sur le sur le triman je vous
remercie ou triment je vous remercie de
votre proposition de rétablissement
prévoyant une exception pour le verre
j'ai l'occasion d'en parler tout à
l'heure que le gouvernement comprend et
et approuve l'avis du Conseil d'État sur
le le réesccri a été a été rendu compte
à lui et et a permis au gouvernement de
proposer l'évolution souhaitée par le
plus grand nombre de voir les voies et
délais de recours pris en compte dans le
périmètre des expérimentations des
articles 13 et 14 merci
merci madame la
ministre je vais suspendre la séance ça
sera reprise dans 5 minutes à
18h25 séance est
suspend
voilà pour cette séance qui s'est
déroulée hier au Sénat séance consacrée
au projet de loi permettant à l'état de
procéder par ordonnance pour simplifier
la vie des entreprises vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 17h 24h Sénat avec tout d'abord
l'hommage du Sénat à Nelson Mandela
suivi du débat sur l'in tion militaire
française en centreafrique très bonne
journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires